[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
day three of the champion showdown here
in st. Louis it was the last day of
rapid and the leaders kept pouring it on
as Fabiano Caruana
Wesley salt and Richard rapport surged
ahead in dominating style to draw close
to clinching victory in their matches
it's time for blitz with some of the
fastest players on the planet gave forth
of razor-sharp action coming up next
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day four of
the champions showdown held here at the
st. Louis chess club we start a day in
the playing hole as we are waiting for
the players to arrive is going to be a
fast-paced explosive day as we are
entering the Blitz portion of the
champions showdown who is going to win
today only time will tell
let's go to the studio and start this
exciting round with Yasir John and
Maurice Thank You hottie and I'm here
with Grandmaster Yasser Sara Juan and
today is all about with the baby
it is indeed Jennifer pleasure is always
to call the action with you and Maurice
and it is about blitz the most popular
form of chess throughout the entire
world but first let's take a look at the
results of the rapid Jennifer well we've
had three exciting days of rapid chess
and we've got some big numbers posted
for the King Richard before and Fabiano
carolina spotting their opponents at an
entire day of blitz yeah 18 6 Wow
in order to even score it these guys
have to get 12 points in the blitz but
in a way we're gonna be looking at the
book scores independently as well yes we
do have two matches that are a little
closer Veselin to polyps got 15 9 verse
Dominguez but arguably linear you know
as a shot to bridge some distance with
his very great clock handling skills and
then we've also got Nakamura vers dude
IV due to just plays amazing and these
faster time controls so can you get the
better of Nakamura today it'll be a
challenge and let's take a look at the
schedule
well the schedule we've got 12 games
today and then we do it all over again
tomorrow yes I can't wait as 24 blitz
games I'm looking at those Nakamura
judaai games yesterday I can only
imagine how they're gonna shock us with
playing really well in the fastest time
control I have this format though
there's a lot of points up for grabs
sure sure there's 24 blitz games one
point at stage for each game and you
need 24 and a half total points to win
the match will we see
winner in one of the matches today I
would bet on yes yes but I have no idea
which max it's gonna be all righty but
let's go over to Grand Master Maurice
Ashley to give us his thoughts on a
today's action well we simply have been
treated to amazing contest so far the
players have brought their a-game at
least some of them and we've just seen
victory after victory after victory a
truly bloody day at the chessboard three
bloody days is it's been incredible you
don't see these kind of numbers normally
in chess usually tends towards more
draws but look at that 37 out of 60
decisive gains white winning 22 black
scoring 15 times certainly these players
are giving it their all to play fighting
chess and one player who has definitely
added a big piece to that total is
Fabiano Caruana the world championship
candidate he's on fire look how much he
gained in rating points over the three
days 47 points and his life ranking has
jumped 11 places to third in the world
well it's that big score again sorry
Cristiano seven wins and only one loss
that has given him that great number but
forget about rapid because now it's all
about blitz chess you got to be
lightning quick and we have some of
those players in this competition
headlined by Hikaru Nakamura he is
simply one of the best police players of
all time but he'll be facing off against
the youngster twenty-year-old yonkers
Abdullah of Poland who won the silver
medal at the world blitz championship
right behind Magnus Carlsen at one point
winning eight games in a row this
matchup will be the one we'll be keeping
our eyes on but of course there are
others as well as we see the standings
there it should be an exciting 12 games
as some of the giants of chess Duke it
out in blitz Thank You Maurice indeed
what matches we have in store and let's
see how they match up what the color
allocation will be in Game one
well yes we've got all the American
players 13 with the black pieces
kind of worked out just coincidentally
yeah they all think the black hat in the
beginning of the tournament so it's
really easy to follow the visitors
iversity Americans here at the champions
showdown and I'm just so so excited to
see that dude I'm Macklemore I match as
well I was definitely in a verse in the
air and those are the two that I really
have my iPhone absolutely and what are
they playing for Gen big money that's
right big bucks here three hundred
thousand dollars on the table 36 K for
each win and 24 K for the runner-up as
you so gracefully put it yet runner up
and in case the matches are tie very
well each get $30,000 so indeed big
money and that close match up let's face
it a four-game points to overcome for
Duda I don't think he's quite there yet
I think that that's a that's a match
that we want to watch but boy when I
think about he Karl and his blitz kills
I think one of the greatest of all times
I agree but you know you just got to do
it one game at a time yes and I think
definitely not considering the score
differential dude I was definitely a
huge underdog right even without the
screw differential we might look at it
and say Nakamura a slight favorite so I
might say moderate or even big favorite
but I don't know it's really hard to say
because this guy did get the silver
medal at ahead of you Carl exactly the
st. Petersburg world blitz championship
and it's all about momentum and blitz
Maurice if you can get on that train
where you could just bang bang bang
three wins in a row you start really
feeling good about yourself
well let me say first of all when you
have a legend like E Cara it's kind of
like I don't know if I can exactly
compare him to to someone like Tom Brady
if the Patriots
mm-hm but it's someone who knows exactly
what this is all about and it's very
comfortable very rarely rattle hikaru in
blitz he says I'm going to stay cool I
don't care if it's three seconds on the
clock I want to pick up some time his
reflexes are astonishing remember that
save he did yes
against dooda dooda I made that one slip
about to made him and he found that at
5:00 break and do dice shaking his head
stunned as you see him walking in now I
mean he has done this so many times but
think about it sooner or later there's
got to be a changing of the guard sooner
or later and just because he's built up
a big resume doesn't mean that the
youngster doesn't have a big chance and
he has shown himself by demolishing
players at the world blitz championship
I believe he only drew Magnus I don't
think Magnus even beat him in their
one-to-one match up I'll have to check
on that but nevertheless Magnus just
barely edged him out to show the point
that too that he is indeed a force to be
reckoned with
well I was gonna say in that world blitz
championship one the setback that Duda
had in that was a twenty one blitz games
was against Hikaru and karo did win in
their individual match if they only
played each other once in st. Petersburg
in the Blitz so as we sit down and drill
in and watch these two guys that this
will be our key matchup for today anyway
yeah I don't know
and there's Richard Report boss Wow what
he did he's done against US Champion
Sam Shanklin amazing Jennifer did you
see that coming
well he's won the euro it was a de
Blitzer or a rapid rapid championship so
it's not like this guy's a slouch you
know quick quick quickly before they
start the outstanding player and the in
this day of blitz just who's gonna score
the most points who's the best blitz
player who's gonna score the most points
Richard
Jennifer you choice come on baby don't
blow it
Wesley uh but you know I'm gonna go with
a favorite yeah I know
look you're young I know you're the Lion
of tomorrow I gotta beat you math again
you're a pig I picked Whaley because I
was that was actually weird dude I got
stopped not by Nakamura not by grease
hook but by Wesley so okay he didn't
play not much but he got stopped by
Wesley so big school put up put up my
cell there but they're not playing today
dude I was playing Nakamura I love that
he repeated the English yeah because
that was really the only time you got
something something with white exactly
and they're repeating oh I was about to
say no III it was gonna be that line of
the benoni that Bharata is such an
extraordinary game in the Rapids but no
it's it's kind of a reverse Hedgehog
Maurice is that how do you describe this
system for white that would be accurate
white feels like he has more than the
hedgehog because he may be going for
don't worry Zachary and yeah I kind of
feel that way too more energy and of
course he's hitting the e5 square over
and over there we see three pieces both
Knights and the bishop on that square
and our Bishop Asics challenging the
night that is quite unusual as we see
this Bishop on that square certainly
curtailing some expansion in the center
because the knight will be pinned but
that night he's so secure it's hard to
push it off the square so it seems like
the bishop is not that useful on that
square but the issue for white right now
is what to do with the center what to do
do you want to hit with D for right now
allow some liquidation or do you want to
start you want to be more constrained
with III d3 I don't see that happening
and giving you anything
do you want to just put pieces right now
just to see what goes on by dropping a
knight on e5 this
lots of questions in particular issue
for white here is where to put the Queen
where does the Queen belong and I was
going to say eight three rook c2 Queen
a1 the already maneuver but he's not
gonna have time to do it after a three
Bishop f6 instantly and a trade we see
now a three Bishop f6 and now a trade on
f6 has indeed occurred and it something
not gonna decide who's gonna take and
he's taking over with a diagonal by
taking with the Queen so he's he's
seized somewhat of the defensive as
white by adopting this Hedgehog setup
indeed yeah well especially with this
trade on f6 maybe a little something a
little bit more challenging with Queen
c2
I thought the movie three frankly was a
little wrong I thought you could just go
Queen c2 not worry about 94 it's not
there's no big issue but Queen c2 Queen
b1 Queen c2 rook d1 and playing for d4 I
think he Cara's gonna say okay I've
already equalized I feel very good in
fact I've got space with this pawn on c5
versus the pawn on d3 move there Queenie
I thought that White's Queen was on a
funny square meet the same file as the
rook and then you take the Queen away
and give him this diagonal to now say
well actually I'm lying I want it back
yeah that was a very strange yes stutter
step but whoa whoa put a knight on e5 Oh
issue there with that bet scary to go
into those pins 19 I've walked into it
Knight d4 this is a very defensive
position for white it doesn't look like
white is looking for much other than
that e5 square
the big key though is that black finds
it very difficult to make any obvious
breaks that's the trick that I wanted to
show Knight d4 Knight takes d4 Queen
takes e5 and that was where my
spidey-sense said wait a minute this
diagonal you walked into a pin but no
Knight D night no 94 by Hikaru he said
okay against her 95 I'll just play 97
96 and I'll give your knight the boot
and these Knights look quite unstable
with that pin on this Merc see two will
walk into the 94 with tempo and I want
to be able to play the move d-iii
is what I want to do is play Brooksie -
but now night before night takes before
you can't play Queen e5 I could just
move the knight right she was where to
put your night eyes white just has
nothing here in this position exactly I
mean if I'm black I'm playing Knight c3
and I'm looking for an edge you mean
you're headed knight c6 partners gonna
go 96 and I start looking for a new
white one some kind of beef or brake but
he has just played this so passively
it's incredible and black now looking to
get the move e5 which was shut down d4
for the long-term
six now King f1 he's looking is to play
white is looking to play King II won and
b4 and maybe using his king to control
what will be the open C file before too
long but yeah this this didn't work out
well at all for Duda oh look at this
move switching and I'll be fine this is
a straight no it's not a pawn sacrifice
explain is hanging so you stop that but
now it'll be is threatened so a nice way
to accept three his knight on the board
and a [ __ ] keep his Bishop on the board
because I wasn't right 92 but his nuance
of Bishop to h3 gave him a chance to
play it without worry so there goes that
Bishop off the diagonal right I think he
car is looking to play a move like
knight c6 but didn't want his Bishop on
d5 to get trapped before the key though
right exactly well you don't want to do
it here because of the back rank mate
right before take on before and there's
a rook c1 check and mate after we trade
right now doubling first and now be fun
or is still on your agenda no question
about it a knight c6 then still be for
no I could take because there's a rook
c7 check
any sick spawn is hanging if I'm black
I'm starting with f5 ooh I was I was
gonna say if I'm black I'm gonna play f5
King f6 and do the slow push on the King
side but h5 complete pairs before we
move that weight in expecting for some
time now is this a strength or a
weakness because black will try to get a
passed pawn on that side and do that to
judge this now by the way look at the
clock 30 seconds to do 238 for naka they
are in full blitz mode now now and yet
they're still playing relatively slowly
and this has been a long thing by not
gonna bury mouse lock to drop I was
thinking look see - look at this move e5
giving away the c5 squared there's that
about a very strange move indeed
that was weird I thought rook C to rook
C to rook c8 was an automatic oh he's
right he's trying to lock down he's
trying to lock down the the square 4 so
he can attack this pawn on b4 that was
his point he thought that he had
strengths here and now f5 making White's
Bishop anemic no no no worry so telling
it that night on c5 is is a monster but
what are you gonna do about the knight
c6 plain Wayne E 4 is another okay so so
he shut down efore so his bishop does
not have to be stock but here it goes
today as is the point really beautifully
for no 996 efore is the issue right g5 e
for dropping or you think you can give
it away anyway this rook a to go yeah of
course
force him on the defensive oh not
Nakamura Wow but oh there goes that b4
point we're talking about right and that
drops that pawn what is Duda going to do
here as Nakamura has gained activity at
a moment no he said no wait I can't give
you too much there and here comes that
be pawn right this was his worry it only
has four seconds left
four seconds yes he's got to play very
much believes does Duda now trading off
and now we're expecting to see a Bishop
g2 happen at some point but but now
morons Hikaru has taken advantage in
this game and somehow that deep re has
become the most important passer three
seconds left Duda in trouble here trying
to figure it out but his King is
seemingly close enough to that ball
tonight just shut him down and he's
ignored that side completely oh he had
to hide his king in that oh and now he's
got to watch out is there a mating
challenge the rook might find a way back
to mating the Royal King ay ay oh there
goes a knight he's okay he's got a de
cover his case busted he's gotta be
busted exactly
King f7 and no no night you said check
oh yeah good now the king he allowed
this move no that night is so strong on
amis and oh this is really boss check oh
he played this last twenty moves so well
he just needs to control the game and
Sam has won his game remember it's touch
move it's touch move and rook takes h3r
often the beautiful floor and okay oh my
goodness there was a bunch of wins by
the way it's a zero-sum game so right
everybody lost as well yes we saw some
big victories in in lots of games for
ventolin lost again wow I just got a
break I just gotta bring up this final
position between Richard and Sam
Shanklin because it's a beauty guys
there's my queen upon endgame equal
number of pawns you think oh it's going
to be a drop Oh what what is white gonna
do about Queen on g1 Oh
- h1 checkmate it's really nice that the
b7 pawn stops me from playing queen c6
exactly no that was before the upset
match but then he picked Ritchie report
for the Blitz yeah what's going on with
that let's take a look
oh here we have anak more of course we
saw that game goes down Nakamura winning
extending his lead 5 yeah no Kara wanna
also with a victory was all about the
leaders extending their leave with one
exception
Sam Shanklin got the job done against
Richard report to start the Blitz off on
a high note and I exactly what you're
saying yeah more respect
Sam Shanklin as the upset guy now he's
going with Richard as the guy who's
gonna score the most points in today's
day of blitz no I mean Fairweather
friend I mean look at that
and all these players are hoping that
Maurice doesn't pick them for the next
throw everything is my curse wait a
second big Duda who big dude it'll win I
did you could do der than I I figured ah
as the best upset guy I see and who
picked Duda to win the whole thing
well we didn't really have them all win
the whole thing we've in there and the
one who was going to go in the most
points today no no I'm not talking much
today I'm [ __ ] minded no overall here
we go here we go the upset did we add
upset upset okay so I'm inconsistent is
what you're telling me
and yet you pick Duda to upset Nakamura
but today you said Nakamura is gonna
beat Duda who am I the only one
thank you very much
[Laughter]
would you believe I am busted oh my
goodness
alright but five decisive games what a
way to start our blitz segment of the
competition Jennifer yesterday we had we
had a game a gamble about whether or not
anybody would lose some time in the
Blitz and what round it would be and
when I suggested there would be four
four losses on the clock
did we see any I don't know obviously to
get a chance to see every single game
but yeah well let's uh I think actually
that our producers are also kind of like
bloodthirsty so if we see an actual time
loss they usually replay it forehead
okay
okay and I'm just replaying
schadenfreude it seems somebody actually
go down on the clock you know especially
if it's not a totally lost position seem
to like like that on it in a sick
twisted way lady watching a horror movie
it's tremendous fun yes I'm watching
people work I mean it's mesmerizing
this is a very very nice final move by
the way between the David Navarro and
Wesley so Wesley obviously he's looking
at his pond he wants to push his pawn to
glory but the problem for Wesley is if
he trades on c4 rook takes e4 Queen
takes e4 pushes his pawn oops there's a
perpetual check that white escapes with
but Wesley found this very nice move
just at the end he played Queen check
maintaining his rook on the open file
and only after f4 now did he push his
pawn and there's nothing that David
could do to prevent the palm from
Queenie and so he he gave it a rest but
okay nice finish by Wesley's they're
getting ready for Game two and a minute
away from the start well that game would
do that I kept his enthralled we really
didn't get a chance to see any of the
other games at play so well I have to
say we saw some really incredible rapid
games we're gonna stick with you
Nakamura as we watch the second battle
between these
to glitch heroes I gotta say naka looks
so cool it's not even funny
now you like my pic I didn't say you're
the one trashing me this guy looked so
cool he just looked like you know what I
belong here
this is what I do make sure we play
blitz all the time all day every day
matter of fact he live streams so he's
the kind of guy I was probably thinking
maybe you can hook up a mic alright I'll
talk talk while I'm playing this guy he
could do that too he's just extremely
comfortable at this time control is a
fun streamer there's no question fun to
watch him as he just shares his thoughts
about the game in real-time with the
audience and already Duda sacrificed
upon having sacked and I don't know if I
like this I still have the feeling it's
all theory film Orissa a lot of about
these efore 85 reactions I feel as
common now there is a trick here that
black has to avoid if Knight takes d4 or
you don't want to take on d5 and fall
for a bishop h7 check ooh he didn't go
for it
alright the the trick I was about to say
is in case of Knight takes d4 this is
the one thing you don't want to do is
allow this kind of a trick with the
Queen coming across and after check you
get to you get to pierce blacks King
saipan shield none of that happened
because after takes your car actually
played 94 oops sorry
you okay well we'll just go to the game
well he has traded off in the middle of
now he is down a pawn but with the two
bishops is due to a little bit of a
slight lead in development for sure with
some pressure on the e line he's gonna
look to get the e4 square as well
exactly
very secure blockade with the bishop on
d6 don't play Bishop f4
rookie four would land on the board so
25 Bishop g5 the Queen was going to
leave anyway
so we're with energy and that's a good
square okay making sure she hits that
pawn on a 2 so the work doesn't leave to
contest the e-file and Bishop d2 was the
quick response by Hikaru's he's looking
to play Bishop c3 yes and create a
battery and maybe try to provoke a few
weaknesses at least try to force f7 f6
or maybe the blockade of the D pawn will
be lifted after Bishop c3 and Bishop f8
not full compensation yet for Duda I
like the extra pawn for a carnival well
you can Nestle on the Queen make right
and I would have really you know fought
with myself to make such a I sure he was
a challenge and it did it anyway didn't
it didn't play take um b6 and double the
pawns okay well now I got a feel it feel
that after Queen takes d4 Knight takes
d4
well equality is strong but the
compensation just really went up for now
9595 might be a tease I'm thinking
Bishop d7 and just chill for the moment
pawn on d5 is well blockaded Bishop d7
yes he's done it looking like a small
challenge for for white oh and he just
weakened that East six square on purpose
okay yeah purposefully because he sees
that he's gonna play king f7 didn't take
much for not gonna leap in there but
just like the moment a weak square
appeared NACA was johnny-on-the-spot why
where yeah what was that all about
and now okay now it's now it's gonna be
full equality you go rook see
with the idea trading and playing rook
c5 no problems at all Duda
even though he's a pond behind he is
really help holding it very well
whoa he took with the rook I thought
Bishop takes exactly keep that another
trade is this gonna go bishop before oh
yeah page five in an amazing ever bishop
takes d4 that shows incredible maturity
to say look I'm a pawn down in a
Bishop's of opposite color ending I know
how to draw this Oh an a3 by naka whoa
okay weird after a for Bishop a5 quickly
or b5 in the Bishop c4 mz4 enforced upon
d'etat will have to go to d6 and you
will now your pawns on the Queen side
are just dead dead and so's nakamura-san
already accepted this is a draw yeah
this is already let's just go too
quickly to the game between Fabiana and
hurry it's an open Sicilian where Wow
hurries kept this King in the center and
he's displayed the move Knight e4 to e5
that knight on e5 you know open Sicilian
players especially the Savannah goons
Scheveningen players amongst us
love those Knights on e5 Knight ytube
not even rookie 1 but night eats you
right away as okay so we see 7 that's
the one to go to let's do it let's jump
to our US Champion remember that we're
also looking at who wins the blitz and
Sam started out with a victory and he
needs lots of them and he's just played
before a sweet move b6 and oh my he is
winning
Sam Shanklin is when he does
get made as Sam avoids me Sam's gonna
play rook we want Bishop a6 and/or
Knight a5 and he's done it
this looks helpless for black guy
exactly queen f1 perhaps okay he does
everything first and though he did mean
c2 Queen c2 was defended and Richard is
playing like he's really really nervous
I don't know what the clock times are
another board and now in threat of route
g1 o do is avoid checkmate
why did he poke all he could have played
Queen dy yeah no I think he fell off I'm
okay that's one out of the four oh my
work oh that was a win oh that was a win
for Sam Shanklin for sure oh and David
Navarre is crushing Wesley so is the
game over
Wow fabbi won again have you won again
but what about Wesley's game is that
already over let's jump to Anna first
yeah David loss I mean David won we got
one
oh my gosh oh I see this final position
the rook has just destroyed White's King
side and let's get acquainted four
seconds left for diamond yes oh my
goodness
what a surprise of course being
facetious yeah okay and the players will
make a draw in a rook and three versus
rook into but draw pictures
playing is Vasily you gotta play rook oh
you didn't play the rook down and then
idea not sure what to do there here
comes the King just a series of checks
would have been pretty good right now
and the King has come to the aegis how
do you make any progress
you don't you just keep that rook
attacking the pawn on h6 and the black
king is tethered to its defense so just
move your king back and forth draw the
first draw everything in between that
was decisive three decisive games of
course he's doing so much makeup but I
feel like psychologically but the real
well we know there blitz is streaky like
that Jennifer you you play you know
three wins in a row now right here you
said take the night with check and I
just couldn't understand why Sam didn't
do that
take the night with check the King has -
I don't know drop back and now because
of the threat of maiden one you drop
your Bishop back your rook covers the
first ring your Bishop covers the other
entry square this Bishop is nothing it's
over played like Queen h4 h4 f - he
would have kept playing but what
happened in the game dude was he took
with the pawn and then came f3 okay
you're still winning after a simple move
for example like Queen f2 one was played
in the game I'm sure it's still winning
right [ __ ] about five Jack okay mate
657 is already well now you're allowing
some tricks Queen e3 you're saying Queen
f2 is we have to shut it down just shut
it down and Maurice well fascinating in
this game there
another idea I'm not trying to yeah yeah
you know just because he's down but
we've we've seen these tactical tricks
typically in like puzzle rush for
example or any night any kind of puzzle
puzzle books you look at the threat is
Queen g1 or anybody feel like Queen
Jiwon he takes you better wrote g1 he
takes you like to move your rook and
bring it to this square but the problem
is your opponent's gonna Queen inmate so
you're gonna Queen and pin that last
rook and then there's no way to pull it
off right so what can you do well for
starters you could move but one idea is
kill this knight first to clean
everything up and then move sorry and
then move your king okay now your threat
is simple you don't put your rook here
and then you're gonna meet him right and
there's nothing you can do about it it's
just game that's it there's nothing you
do about except give his Queen away the
Reds play Queen d1 well quick right
Queen d1 allows this other idea check
and this makes me so you other so if you
try to defend the back rank you run into
that that's great and if you try to stop
him if you don't then he's just gonna
play Queen down so that was really a
nice way to win but here we go as Sam
black wit sing but he ended up flagging
in this game they're three seconds he's
hesitating it's making that Queen it
takes too long right there and he had to
play queen c1 or queen d1 d1 and here's
our results to cover whoops you won me
and Richard report on that winner's
circle so the bad news is I wanted time
to make a comeback you know I'm not
gonna lie the the good news is maurices
pick just looks a little bit better
right also remember yesterday I said you
know I might have to do a 10k if there
was no flat fall right
wait who did you say Jen you guys
attraction when he picks again yes a was
going to win the blitz blitz wrong
Wesley yeah that's all I love I really
like that Wesley pick right if I had a
second chance that was a rule although
he is only one one so far Christian
putting I read a little jealous of his
choice that's a good choice he didn't
pick Bobby in the first round but that
was also a misunderstanding of upset
Fabiano Carolina st. Louis's own
challenge magnus carlsen for the world
championship in November came ever so
close and now he's trying to say hey you
might not have seen it in London but I'm
not really good right well he hit the
trampoline big time in the rapid as he
went from 16th to 3rd I believe or was
it 14th 2/3 can he pull something like
that off again
I mean Harry will say I don't know what
I was thinking when I accepted my
invitation I mean no it's just a bad bad
bad experience for hurry as he's just
not gotten gotten into a groove he was
tremendously out raided by his opponent
you know I mean a hundred points and
hundred points for what rapid 100 points
in classical Oh Harry Krishna no hold on
what was the matchup in terms of Rapids
and there's the handshake it looks like
a d4 has been essayed in it in classical
it's a hundred points but I know they're
not playing classical but still it's
nice he doesn't get the play against
Bobby very much exactly there is there
100 points in class of all did every
krishna go down at 27 29 I don't know
almost 12 in the world it was worse when
did that happen
by the way English open man
Oh hiya open it with her guys as maybe
we should maybe we should look at the
what do you what do you think now and
our game is fun I can tell you it's
already a big imbalance
after this move f4 I mean I played this
McKenna's floor English opening system
since I was 12 and I never played the
move f4 by what do de sá I mean wow
that's a crazy move okay
he's obviously he's ambitiously thinking
to plant his night on the e5 square jet
but isn't that deep on a little bit
weird well he's trying to fix it with d4
before no structure is going to be weird
well d8 well he's got to play Bishop III
to keep the defense of the d4 pawn going
knowing to be defending already I know
whoa smell the coffee I've got it I got
a tactic says dude give me that Bishop
g5 trick okay I didn't see that coming
555 26 what happens to d5 it is no
longer a target
it's a passed pawn that's gonna be what
he's counting on the fact pawn sacrifice
to get a passer yes and to neutralize
the pressure on the defense elute lee
and black is not developed on the
queenside so white is looking for quick
development and temptation positional
pressure the whole nine this is a
fantastic model and he found you you
were talking about that f4 move just
giddy up to the f5 square and now knock
is like whoa I didn't see this one
coming
and that Bishop g5 threat that d5 move
on Aziz fight all of it is what he's
starting to calculate and look at much
clock time he burned after that monster
movie
and I think he's gonna have to play your
line Jen I think he's gonna have to take
with the pawn and suffer the
consequences of Bishop g5 Queen D 6 and
D 5 and let's go
played Queen D 6 this is for instantly
just where do you want to keep the lady
don't think he wants to draw no no no I
don't like it yeah back on f6 yeah okay
but d5 right now Queen C 3 because of
the pin right you're gonna take that
pawn just realize you're that great I
guess rook c1 I don't know but be fun
funny it takes on c6 work takes you on
takes b7 worked whoa what is that -
amazing moves dude I would so sack the
exchange if I were black here but yeah
I'm not sure it's gonna make what do you
play this move Bishop csepp maybe to
remove the blood may be to remove the
pin from that way so that way just a hit
it's a serious yes that was the purpose
okay not a bishop has dropped back to e8
and now hmm that ball I could also keep
going down the board with d6 but then
rook d8 again and you failed so that's
not gonna work
but he said hold on d6 and this that
Bishop on g2 could get Unleashed oh wow
quickly while they're there they're
contemplating I just want to show the
audience a line that Jennifer came up
with which is a really sweet line attack
dick with d5 Queen takes c3 she had this
tactic worked out where it takes you
sacrifice your queen but check this out
after taking on b7
there's no way black and stop white from
reemerging with the Queen and a material
edge that's a beautiful tack thank you
right now white is actually down an
entire queen of art exactly you could
probably take this guy but then after
you take some queens that would have
been a wonderful wonderful win a long
think by the way by Judah while you're
standing back that again entire time yes
Louise entire edge his time edge and
finally some of the rook b1 which puts a
bit of pressure on Nakamura because he
really wants to play b5 but that feels
soft but that just didn't seem right so
you decided just to bring his Knight out
giving back Lucas crashed with a 7-6 now
Queen a six hits the that's the rook and
the base pawn the c4
what is he aplenty of Queen b3 should be
able to cover that right but Knight b6
it might be six No Bishop e7 watch out
alert right you can't move that but he's
got one more move though and he the
mortar should enjoy 8 e8 how does he
deal with Numbi 7 looks a little bit
vulnerable maybe six looks tricky you're
gonna have to second exchange somewhere
how do you deal with and those bishops
on the back row just stopping any
incursions Heidi's playing rook to be 5
but with 22 seconds Maurice yes a lot of
time Knight b6 oh and there he goes he's
won an exchange what a move c4 what by a
car what an interesting idea and he
slipped across a crook b8 quickly and he
comes anyway it's nothing but these
pieces look really good yeah exactly
that's what I've been thinking - I mean
yeah he's giving the impression that
I've got a blueprint for victory
seconds left react cannot just relax
you've got to start making moves oh my
gosh rook takes b5 and Bishop b6 that
looks like game over Rory should be sick
it's just King a move yeah no problem
this is resigns bishop be 65 what's
wrong with just taking the night also
but you're right there should be six is
strong rook takes Queen does doesn't
call my goodness rude all right that
night on III this is just over his grave
one more move no threat da discomfort
right yeah
lurking smiling mate somewhere the light
squares are pretty well covered so just
dropping back with his rook Oh a trick
second trick try for Queen f8h five is
over
so no situ should do the job
three instead and this is now finally
resigns what a boss exhibition by an
acara
wow it makes it look so easy so
effortless why did I pick against them
navara and so this match is tied up as
far as the blitz of course so big lead
in the overall match and David is just
one in exchange it's busted Wesley is
going to lose back-to-back games as
David navara an exchange to the good I
just don't know what the clock times are
ahead on the time also oh the head and
the clock is everything just take on g5
now the g5 and rook already that was one
easily but easily Manaus Oh what's this
is this the h pawn is gone
your picks that looking great either I
know why
shoutout to David who decided to wear a
t-shirt today very classy individual I'm
sure he was dying
so wear a suit jacket but actually I I
heard from the arbiters that they wanted
to make very clear that today the dress
code with a little bit more relaxed
exactly and that's because wearing a
suit jacket while playing blitz can be
very difficult it can actually make you
play slower it's a so you show up to the
game in a suit but then you can take off
your suit Jack and you actually see
right there Davis Grantchester jacket is
on it exactly like result let's Bobby
did it yeah oh my goodness stop it
we don't want to look at that match
anymore it's over good mall let's take a
look at our results Jim how many
decisive games that we've seen in this
the third it wasn't it wasn't
necessarily well there were decisive
games three decisive games the same
men's numbers before I believe but Sam
drew Sam drew and cEPAL of Drew and
Dominguez drew but Wesley so going down
a duda winning due to losing and Davidov
are winning and and but Bobby just like
wow you know the problem is that for
strong players when they have nothing to
play for and that's the feeling that
Hari he's looking I really don't want to
play anymore this match is just dead
it's over and he has no real motivation
to play he's embarrassed he's playing
the second best player the second
highest rated player in the world and
you're losing game after game and the
other guys confidence is way up no
matter what the position on the board
you're losing right you could be better
on the board sorry you're gonna lose the
game you know this has happened I've
been in the same situation where you're
you lose the lost games you lose the
drawn games you lose the one game
because the person just has your brain
and your you can't play you're on tilt
and you can't play and that's where
Harry is he just cannot put up a fight
right he's haribol situation for him
very very bad and the results change
here we have it we had three decisive
games with Nakamura extending his lead
Bobby extending his lead
the person to actually narrow the score
is David navara as he's got two plaits
wins but such a huge lead amount by
Wesley he's gonna have to win several
more to try to get back in the overall
mass and there you see Fabiana closing
and on that twenty four and a half point
score it's got 18 points from the rapid
three out of three today in the blitz
giving him a total of 21 all he needs is
twenty four and a half points gen3 nine
points more and Bobby's got his match
he'll be the first to clench and we're
gonna get started with round seven quite
soon round four round four of the blitz
but yes I gotta tell you when I was
listening tomorrow you says thinking a
little bit about poker and how the poker
format that people probably go the most
on tilt in is heads up and that's
because you don't have a lot of recovery
time you know if you lose a big hand
then it's your move again you know
whereas in like a right six or nine
players a lot of times are folding right
and I think that's very much 20 minutes
for the hand exactly in another big hand
it might be another 20 minutes
that's very analogous to why tilts and
emotional it's so emotional things are
very similar in blitz just because
emotional trends because you don't have
time to recover right and in this one
format in particular the breaks are
pretty short right so you don't have a
lot of time to recover there's you can't
go back to the hotel and like you know
sleep it off well bang your head against
the wall oh you can always do that but
as a poker professional are you you have
that awareness of like okay you got to
be calm but also not to go on tilt and
if you do go on so a lot of the time the
recommended thing to do is to stop
playing for a little while because
usually if you're playing it or if
you're playing a cash game you can leave
at any moment and for instance if you're
playing on an internet server and you're
trying to get a higher rating you can do
the same thing you've lost three games
well maybe your until maybe you're not
in a goods owned you can just stop
playing and I saw Malcolm or actually
recommend that once in an interview
about how to improve
your your boots rating he said if you're
doing really well don't stop playing
okay and if you're doing badly work
exactly
so your advice to hurry would be this is
he's signed a contract and it's a
tournament where there's a lot of money
at stake a lot of glitz and rapid rating
but if you think of it in a way as
preparation for perhaps even bigger
stages like World Cup or World
Championship where you have to training
the classic the red and the Blitz
playoff you have to deal with difficult
emotional situations there like of
course when Fabiano was down two games
in the rapid and he still needed to play
that third game right exactly
one and a half right yeah yeah well they
like to play the third game and that's a
tough situation in this type of training
where it's a awful situation you don't
want to keep playing but you have to
right I think that's good
emotional training for some other
situations that unfortunately every
chess player every competitor is gonna
have to face at some point and bingo
exactly right there are we saw a
contrast but Maurice you've got the live
reading well I just looked at a stat
that you know anybody over 30 he's not
gonna be happy to see in blitz in blitz
there are only three players in the
world who are in the top 16 who are 30
or over it's a young man's game it's
absolutely blitz more than any there's
one player who is 31 and that's a bet
you won't guess the next two you might
get one but I don't think you're gonna
get to I'm gonna go with the rush
in Greece shock nope I'm gonna go with
Grichuk is not currently in the top 16
he's number 17 I was gonna tell you it's
not unknown
oh the two are Peters fiddler would you
said Russian I thought yeah he's gonna
get one it was gonna be one of them and
Micky Adams
yeah Micky Adams so they're just
repeating their opening earlier but just
to say guy like Harry Krishna he might
have aged out already at 31 or 32 years
old
raising your lesson you're 30 or older
you got to face off against these young
guns who's I mean they're they're fast
nerve twitching he's just so superb it's
incredible that is an amazing story more
at 31 like being aged out of Blitz I
know I can compete of course not one of
the great in the world
oh good at bullet yes I correlations are
amazing of course he's no slouch and not
any of the formats but okay what do I
the way Knight takes d4 and this a he
Cara had played Knight e4 in that
earlier game reference that Knight takes
d4 this was the where I said you don't
want to take on d5 and allow that Bishop
takes h7 check trick but you have to
play Knight b6 in order to recapture the
pawn this way and let's see what he Carl
did after Knight b6 yeah at least on my
board no there's something on f5 did he
move yeah oh yeah you put the night
there he put the night there so he's
he's eyeballing an opportunity to win
the two bishops and he's giving back the
yeah we're gonna go back to moves just
one one one that's it that's it
I love this construction of the pieces
on the D line although yes it's very
rare that you see this happen 8 but all
eight squares on the D file
occupied by something you just don't see
that geometric every day of the week but
it of course quickly changed
eat scoops of ice cream yeah yeah I can
relate to that Bishop f4 okay I just
don't see how he car is gonna make hay
out of this position d6 I think you're
just asking for too much trouble after
d6 Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes
d6 and it's happened I think it carros
overplayed his hand with this move d6
well he's gotten the two bishops he's
gonna argue yeah but well as any fallen
considerably behind though g3 and
development g3 okay that's an important
tempo because Bishop takes h2 was on tap
sorry where did you put this Bishop is
his question right now does he play
Bishop e5 and limit White's opportunity
to develop that Bishop on c1 that's the
most active move for sure but he could
also go Bishop h6 to ensure that any
time this knight on D 2 does move away
he can trade off the dark square bishop
so it's a challenging moment Duda not
playing in stick Bishop takes the one I
think he wanted to give up whoa the
second bishop in whoa ok the trick but
there's some tricks think is maybe
Bishop takes d2 queenie fine that's not
much of a trick hold on
1:5 I don't believe yeah well I was
trying to do a double hit one of the
worst yeah I'm thinking something on the
file so what challenge Bishop takes
Knight see what does he takes instead I
wonder what he had in mind after Bishop
takes Queen takes whiskey carros choice
and by the way just while you I mean
we'll watch the game but that's that you
said about 31 year olds and blitz it's
so amazing is it also true for the
ladies do the labor every single master
who's a woman is alive so I think the
ladies tournaments kind of screw young
not only because of the importance of
you know youth and getting stronger but
also because in previous generations
women weren't quite as serious about to
ass so we might need to wait another
generation to find out the the the the
ideal age and the women's section I mean
excuse me excuse older than women right
the strong with the top women are gonna
be the better players at all time
controls I would think all that because
all the top players like you said are
all alive and they're all GM's
but anyway will can argue that another
time this one this one here I don't like
what do ii did at all at all at all at
all at all
that's a strange move by he car Queen Oh
Queen takes b2 there is a trick Queen
takes b2 bishop d4 alert alert alert the
Queen on b2 will be trapped
so Queen why Queen takes b2 Bishop
before I think oh my goodness why didn't
he take I'm b2 because this is usually
the very end game when you have the two
nights that you want to avoid I would
think so I would think so
this looks like Botvinnik taking you
school yeah I do not want to play you're
smiling oh my god your face right now
I'm all aglow the problem for the
Knights the problem is although you see
centralized Knights here the problem is
those squares are not secure you don't
have an anchor pawn defending this
knight on d5 and you don't see anywhere
that the knight can go to that will have
a new anchor square so right now
Nakamura is trying to figure out where
to put his pieces right get his bishops
out the way if he could put them on F 1
and E 1 and say that they go they just
get out the way find some squares now
he's bringing getting his Bishop to the
B 3 square you see that night leave d5
quickly so there goes one Bishop me say
yeah let's play let's play against your
Brooks and he's we see this trade and I
said let's now get rid of the rooks and
we're gonna fight these nights with my
bishops you've got to be attractive
the Bishop's in this kind of position
unless the Knights getting her ass in
some kind of strange way but I don't see
how he does it well that's a beautiful
ending too no doubt about it but let's
just quickly take a look at the game
between Sam and Richard as it looks at
me like Sam's closing in on a victory
here guys he's an exchange down but he's
got two pawns for it and he's got this
move Queen h4 check on tab to win the
exchange back as well as knight h5 this
is exciting
total cruise control for our US Champion
man how big a point swing was that well
because he could have won the game you
lost one time you'd be able to have like
nine and a half against eighteen and a
half you would still be well beyond now
look at those nights
four nights are getting harassed by the
bishops and seven seconds for Duda on
the clock to 20 seconds for Nakamura
tick-tock your time is going that was a
lot of time spent on those last couple
of moves and Nakamura knows he hasn't by
the tail this is also the advantage of
the bishops is like you can do so many
quick and easy Musa b7 is a threat yes
be careful be careful indeed Bishop back
to g2 perhaps and now for b7 is the
threats we get to leave right and here
comes the king to join the party
yeah not find any anchor squares no
there's no good protections in the
middle of the board however this move
does set up for a night fork with Knight
to e5 check to eliminate one of those
that was yes it's a long-term one but
now he's trying to rise the king he's
trying to use the king as a Park Road a
lot better five seconds but not
by the way even on the clock that's
right check on C Sixers do it yeah I
mean check on e7 any car is it what's
the problem and King now and he's in
trouble
six let's go no another Jackie five and
king of six come on e kuru
no and he's just got some time on the
down to be able to repeat that's he's
remaining no no thank you said he carro
seven seconds on the clock might be four
that's a committal move that point is
weak now knock mores not accepting a
three move repetition from alpha zero in
that position for check no not quite yet
because that pawn on you got or absence
before he created that weakness oh no
not a change tomorrow up H for there it
is he's got a take now don't think whoa
whoa take time decision King e5 look
swimming that's it you miss Johnny ball
what is that that's just a random check
yeah disgusted with himself at the end
there as he Carl well I was raised also
with the Michael Botvinnik school of
chess from far distance I might add and
linear Sam one of course we saw that it
was going down his fourth blitz game in
a row and the trot as it just goes from
bad to just atrociously
and here we got four decisive win
decisive that's right as nothing more
and a half against Duda and we've got
Fabiano Carolina
Oh oh my god the other blips matches
yeah they're actually pretty close to
right topple of Dominguez two and a half
in favor of Navarra and two and a half
in favor of Shanklin so three of these
blue chamber going toe-to-toe but right
naka and Carolina just can't stop
winning and Christian at korilla is with
Viviano as we're taking a slightly
longer break than usual bobby's of
christen
thanks guys I'm here with Fabiano
Caruana who is simply making a statement
in his return here at the same delicious
club first of all congratulations to
take us through through the match up to
this point in the Blitz section yeah
it's I mean I things couldn't have
really gone better
it's not like I've been getting crushing
positions out of the open or anything
but when tactics start usually I come
out ahead and especially the last game
at some point he started not playing me
positionally but then when it became
sharp I mean I was just I guess
tactically more aware through this
dominant performance how do you keep
motivated for the rest of the match well
it's still first of all not over I mean
it's you know of course I'm huge and
probably instrumental elite but it's
still not theoretically over and even if
the match is decided before that and
then I still find motivation to play
good games and there's also rating at
stake which there's no the biggest
motivator but it's something what do you
think it's the reason for the collapse
of pantalla
because he's such a strong player yet he
cannot find himself well and puts it can
go wrong very quickly and you play
multiple games for a short period of
time I mean it's easy to get tilted and
if things start to not go your way I
mean we've seen this on both sides you
know players who start a run they they
they can win you know eight nine games
in a row and players who start to
collapse they can lose many games in a
row it's happened to me on both sides as
well well thank you very much Farley for
your time and
good luck in the rest of your games guys
back to you Thank You Christian and
indeed blitz is about momentum and often
times when you get on a roll you just
think to yourself why doesn't this
always happen I don't I always get to
play and win a series of games in a row
Jennifer why aren't you always the best
version of yourself exactly I mean why
can't you all have that's my that's the
question when you're when you're rolling
in chess that's what it feels like that
I know that 10:00 a.m.
coffee high or 9:00 and depending on
when you wake up 6 a.m. it's like you
got it the whole day and you got to turn
that switch I remember this in Buenos
Aires Argentina it's like 3 o'clock in
the morning there's a knock on the door
I open up the door and there's Magee all
night off one of the great legends of
chess and he says to me Jasser Jasser we
have to play blitz
I said Miguel I'm in my PJs I'm sleeping
he says yes but right now I know I could
play the brilliancy of my life he wanted
to play blitz and he had no opponent
sometimes you're just in a mood and
you've made this point we said about
rapid chess that momentum is don't trust
it don't trust momentum because you have
these long games and some individual
game could possibly turn things around
but in blitz you absolutely trust
momentum unfortunately for the person
who's losing it happens you start
getting hammered and you have to play
again and you don't want to play just
now another game and another game and
it's happening it's coming at you so
fast it's like somebody punching like a
boxer hitting and then a flurry of
punches back and forth and they're just
coming at you and you need time to
recuperate get out it's painful
where's the battle where's the Bell and
before you know it you're knocked out
and that's what's happening right now as
how a Christian is going down in a way
that just isn't logical at all isn't
yeah he's a logical based on how strong
he is but it's very logical because his
mind is gone and it's all foggy now
looking like a beast
absolutely and so far let's take a look
at our predictions well
Maurice and I are not on fire today at
the prediction Department yet still got
another 16 rounds you guys should be
proud it's all about competing and being
20 able to compete today yeah this is
today's you're going toe-to-toe dude has
been on all the games that he's only
managed one draw whereas the happies
opponent Hari has lost all of his games
so Christian looking like in gold kind
of lineup with our our predictions
thanks guys we're gonna take a quick
break before we get into the games 5
through 8 here at the blitz I'm gonna
leave you with story time with the Asura
oh no in the late 80s there were
numerous private tournaments that were
really of an extremely high prestige and
this is a story about one tournament I
was playing in Tilburg we're staying at
a very very nice hotel and each of the
players had their own bungalow the TV
had a video cassette player that was
played from the lobby so from your TV
you could watch touch TV if you want a
German TV or you could play the movie
that was being looped from the reception
I really movie buff and I turned on the
movie and was watching this movie and it
was a movie that was getting
progressively weirder and weirder and
weirder and it was called The Shining
and it was about a writer who is
descending into madness
I decided that I wanted to watch the
rest of the movie Malathi this up the
London flight Margot I didn't like what
this movie was going so off I went into
the lobby you know sighs as I walked in
the door
Bobby it was like 10 people suddenly
cheering me giving me an applause as I
sat down to watch the movie and as I
looked around I realized that I was the
very last participant of the tournament
they had all been questioned movie as
well but they had all collectively and
individually come into the Lafayette
earlier than I did I was the last
holdout was really funny we watched a
movie together - the final conclusion is
no lobby
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen hi I'm John
Herschel former NFL offensive lineman
there's not too many things more
intimidating than staring into the face
of a 300-pound NFL defensive lineman
beginning March 18th the best chess
players in the US will be staring each
other down from the coveted US
Championship title this will be the 11th
championship held at the st. Louis chess
club featuring 12 of the top chess
players in America fans can watch all
the action in person at the st. Louis
chess club or online for more
information go to st. Louis chess club
org st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015
SLU partner with the st. Louis chest
clip to start a top tiered collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
Peace inception slough obtained second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate Chess Championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University you may have heard about st.
Louis's world-class museums art history
science even magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by you
whose kids it is st. Loup is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back for champion showdown
the Kings and the Kings today are
playing blitz yeah as we see a couple of
blowouts so far in the blitz with
Fabiano racking up the four Oh scores
and Nakamura at three and a half but the
other blitz matches heavy weight clothes
exactly maybe it's time to turn our
spotlight perhaps to our US Champion
let's leads two and a half one and a
half against Richards report even though
his rapid was a disaster and look at
them go they're fired up Jen he's coming
with a lot of desires say man maybe I'll
win the Blitz even though you got me in
the rapid and maybe if I would not blitz
you you're respecting even if the match
turns out in your favor okay
Knight if I was about to say Knight e4
Knights love centralized outpost 94 was
ideal and Sam wanted to get rid of his
LightSquared bishop so that he could
play for eise Evan a 5-star swears but
did he make this right choice there this
is all timing if the nice can get an
anchor quickly then yes
but there goes Eve four on the board
trying to show that the light squares
are his indeed and E 5 will be very
difficult to execute without giving up
some kind of weakness in the position
but it seems to me that you got if I was
well-timed here you got to do it he just
just play the move and you might end up
with an isolated pawn and he's done it
at night takes but he's hitting that
bishop on f3 and the only way you
produce an isolated pawn is by trading
and he's done so traded on e5 very
quickly and then took on d5 and he's
gotten that isolated pawn that he wanted
after pawn takes he didn't recapture
with a knight that's a little bit of a
surprise Queen 3 and now Queen f6 very
quickly giving away the pawn on d5
whoa but Sam is part yeah no wait a
minute if it was black to move Queen f4
would be quite a powerful move as Queen
in the world
the h2 the bishop takes d5 was forced
but wait a minute I'm a pawn grabber
happy vacation for giving away this
brain so quickly so instantaneously and
now stopping to think about the position
well if he could trade Queens the last
thing he wants to do is trade night for
Bishop he'd rather have the opposite
color Bishop position with some pluses
for himself being upon down but Knight
takes Bishop leaves him with the minor
pieces being dissimilar and that kind of
formation with the bishop not proving
anything would be fine as soon as the
knight enters the game so that's why he
avoided capturing this pawn and we go
back capturing the bishop I should say
and he's instead played rook to d8 and
rook d1 instantly was the response this
this is the game right now of the Bishop
on b7 after b6 Bishop to b7 what a
strange choice 96 he would have loved to
play Bishop to f3 didn't want to face
the consequences of Bishop f3 Queen at 4
but how can that Bishop be good on b7 96
threatening nice c5 instantly and the
knight is also gonna venture towards the
Kings side as well so here's a trade
I don't think Samson allowed double
trade over hooks although it's starting
to look a little bit draw if he could
trade Queens okay cuz again the opposite
call it Bishop but this position nice
rook takes rook t1 on the board
yeah 95 would force a trade of rooks and
then it's rate of Queens but that would
be good because they need to have a
knight a 4 at the end of the day the
night c4 hitting your Bishop Knight c4
it's the bishop that's a such an
important tempo yeah so that so he wants
so Richard still for choice with his
extra pawn but I don't know because it
just looks like white I mean black
should be able to get some play here but
95 allows too many trades right unless
there's another trick waiting somewhere
in in the position but it doesn't seem
like you can organize his pieces anyway
they all night there I've Queenie for
anything played for Queen geo whoa this
Queen this is a trick we're talking
about a queen c1 action in the position
exactly hello I'm
careful because your Bishop on b7 is
hanging under threat
this one just taking advantage of the
Knights temporal displacement on a5 and
this move is a boss move
so what halls after g3 g3 to make room
yeah I don't think it can go down and
but I could take your Bishop and then
probably then take your pawn and then
after Knight and he's done it he's he's
given back his pawn Knight takes b7
Queen takes b7 Queen c1 check oh oh I
got another one okay Bishop g9 h b7 then
bishop g3 you take Queen c1 check don't
I pick off your knight
I like that no no 97 c3 is on a
different way
take it on c3 now same deal he's after
that night and he's left the bishop as a
poor piece on b7 - no I like Sam's
choice a lot this is Richard clear did
not play this well Jennifer not at all
say and found the action on the dark
squares you got to use your pluses and
he found it with this tactical shot
Bishop takes on c3 and now you know
disadvantage the black anywhere the
whole idea of being B takes c3 Queen
takes a 3
this Knight on c5 is actually much
better than this Bishop much better
which is we saw it the first time we
didn't like that place I was about to
say isn't a time for Bishop c6 Bishop 8
type of action or Queen B 528 check
followed by Bishop b5 similar things I
got a line up got a line up on that f7
right c4 Knight e4 looks like a good
start oh then I said it's a d6 96
careful for that again I'm thinking you
know Sam made this big incursion on the
dark squares thanks to his dark squared
bishop it's all about getting some light
square action if you're Richard you want
to play 96 and maybe Bishop c6 to e8 and
you'd be back
you know role reversal what I want to
say so 96 we're expecting and how does
Sam want to deal with that
because that will be a big threat of
Queen takes f7 and mate on f8 by the way
was bishop by the way that hmm that
crazy sacrifice I talked about on g3 was
it good was the best move and was better
for black exactly he should have been
looked great
tiny plate was not the best Bishop takes
g3 and now I'm not even sure it'll what
was this move all about Bishop c8 he
could have played Bishop to see 68 or 96
Queen f6 played now so that's a clear
thing tricks there's a trick on EA ties
there's a trick on e85 is Bishop Bishop
a6 look at that he's saying take my
piece because he has a trick on EA we
nee 8 and then 98 Bishop d5 doesn't that
miss the trick
Queenie he's got 7 seconds left
as we jump in and why is he said yes
because that's what not getting killed
on well that's a different down upon and
about to go down more stuff three
seconds clock time is bad oh dear
yeah and these positions about to
collapse oh he's got to find a move and
there goes the Bishop takes Knight takes
very second pawn he's taking the rook
takes the rook check offends the pawn on
g6 he's hitting f2 whoa
and we've got a first victory of the day
by Judah who now holds one and a half to
three and a half hours Nakamura but
let's jump in to Navarro who's got to
the better of what we saw so far in the
Blitz okay by the way the biggest one we
note that the mink is one here great two
victories for Davinia's one for Veselin
so far today I want to close my eyes as
Fabiano won again guys either oh wow
he's gonna close out the match one of
two games when it rains it pours so when
seven in a row but this one navara about
to win back his piece
he just sacrificed I came to get now
Abby did indeed and you can't win this
position
no exactly of course if that's is a
remaining game with that fob yes getting
off to that 500 start Nakamura finally
far was it has to be a little careful
yes about say with that bad King that
King is horrendous and run g5 now what's
the problem well you decide to move his
king up i there goes a second whoa wait
a minute black is in big trouble yeah
that is awesome
he's lost Wow so a loss ending just on
activity alone and navara showing his
stuff whoa I don't think any of our
picks are good today but speak for
yourself young buck
Fabiano 5-0 Christian an amazing there
Wow recap that round first well how many
decisive games weren't there
Jennifer because I just Nakamura is just
amazing he's a man on fire but not Bobby
Oh
dude I won and then we have he won that
Fabi one we saw Navarro in Sam Shanklin
lost because he there it is
Sam shank a little lost because he
missed that tactic that's right so here
you have it yes three Americans win and
Nakamura and Shanklin went down okay and
there you can see the Blitz score is
that David Navarro escort three and a
half against Wesley so is one and a half
uh it's it's 1-0 navara right right yeah
I think that's that was the this way
that's a typo but they but Navarre its
that means actually that only two
Americans won this round and the total
loss has a 3-2 result in the Blitz and
which are two and a half so Sam Shanklin
and Richard are actually going
toe-to-toe and that's the only match in
the Blitz that's even at this point Sam
is just so upset yes of course because
here this is a position we saw go by
lightning quick and I'd noticed this
tactic Knight takes b7 the point being
Queen takes b7 runs it in to Bishop
takes on g3 and after pawn takes Queen
c1 check and this night is gonna drop
off the board with checks I might add
after check no matter what you do takes
guards just pawn and his black goes up
upon in this position after Knight takes
b7 it's best to play Knight c4 and go
into that position where black will be
fine anyway however Sam went for the
other line with Queen c1 check and after
a king g2 Bishop takes on c3 now already
the injured is spotted a win with Queen
b8 Bishop d5 that's hard to see the game
ended up night C for Bishop b2 Bishop c8
a couple of weird moves these were not
impressive but it was this move suddenly
a little bit of trickery in the moment
now I had noticed it from here I didn't
know where to put the bishop like hide
it somewhere he decided to put it on a6
kind of suggesting you take it it's
funny because the suggestion is if you
take it you're gonna lose so why doesn't
Sam take it by instead play Bishop d4 it
seemed
that he didn't realize the point of
night of the fact that there's a hanging
piece because the point was you couldn't
take it because of this check King up
and now oops
98 with check always difficult to see
knights landing on the back row on the
other side of the board remember the
Kramnik dropped a mate I believe it was
the fritz yes it was a computer match I
was there for that man yes drop mate
because there was a knight sitting on f8
and the cootie play Queen eight said the
computer played Queen 87 mate think it
was like what the night is on the back
rank is writing work these are moves
that are very difficult to see and so
you want to make sure you train for
these kind of moves but Sam missed it in
the Blitz moment and ended up losing a
game that he was okay no quick consensus
guys what what imagine Mora how are you
feeling Maurice which match has gotten
your undivided attention we need to see
linear and Vasily and go at it once
though guys I mean we got to give
everybody some play a little bit and
we'll get back to do to Nakamura because
they're so good and probably will spend
a lot of time with them in later maybe
tomorrow for sure okay right now we
should look at topi and omegas there
looks like they're punching each other
pretty good you want to see that or you
want to see you do that okay let's do
linear to take a look at his games
especially after he's lost but let's
start with the Dominguez and we'll keep
an eye on other games as well it's
unfortunate that we are not following
fabi's games he's running up such a
number that he's a trampoline and wrap
it and he's gonna hit the trampoline and
Blitzen already
now Wow what because of this massive
rating gain again yeah
47 rating points were gained in the
rapid I think that was only top I wanna
so unofficially his ninth in the world
in a blitz Wow and that's just it's sort
of unfair I'll be beating up on one guy
and just taking all the other promises
and you can see how are you Christian a
the body language says yeah topalov a
former world champion leads in the match
he has black facing linear Dominguez
from originally from Cuba who's just
changed federations to the United States
Chess Federation welcome linear to the
US and he trails 18 to 11 wins great guy
it's wonderful to happen for us because
it's personality esepcially nice person
he's just so really yeah yeah absolutely
93 let's go see five all very very
standard opening play who will be the
first to deviate Knight takes c3 it's a
little bit off the beaten track and the
reason that vessel and took on c3 is
Veselin is anticipating that the C file
will be the challenge that both players
will want to bring the rooks to the C
file and he wants the bishop to be a
target on c3 and as soon as I said that
he didn't go for the knight f6 d5 but
captured right away on d4 so 95 tickling
the bishop on d3
and we're seeing an endgame in the game
between Duda and Nakamura nothing
special for us to turn to but just
noting it's just there's an end game
probably not the wildest one we're gonna
get a chance to look at today
well vessel is gonna be very very
pleased with the outcome of the opening
he's already gotten with two bishops and
no doubts after move like Bishop c6
Bishop b5 white will be very very happy
to make a repetition instead a capture
on f3 this game sorry guys got to call
it as boring as can be bishops of
opposite color take us to an excuse am
Shanklin game that is of course a tight
match when it comes to the Blitz he just
played d5 did Sam write your board so
you could see the position and he's
decided to sacrifice me yeah right here
right here play d5 monster move and
after of course Bishop takes he would
rip that Bishop off the board but pawn
takes was played instead and if we can
catch up with the give Knight d4 and the
King moved and now looking you can see
rapport it's like a complete control as
he's trapped the bishop on e4 sense of a
piece yeah nice but he's got a couple of
pawns for it does Richard but it's not
sufficient compensation leave that all
layers are playing very quickly gen
what's the time position and clock is
good exactly look at a d6 pawn about the
drop absolutely this is a science
this is terrible yeah what is this oh
this is a trick no it's not a good one
rook takes d5 that's and the a 7-point
didn't drop now am i blind to that no
reason to give him anything at all Sam
just own it
Oh g4 looks like you could rip your
heart Hammond lay Bishop e5 to play the
movie sorry Jen you were about to say
that if Sam wins this game
plus one in the blade but he got another
pawn yeah he got another pawn just drop
the knight back to me [ __ ] you put it on
c6 Bishop c5 it's all good but just play
g4 get that Bishop on g2 in the game and
you'll be a piece I've done it there it
is that's cruise control as everything
is going brilliantly for our US Champion
Knight e5 look at the beautiful
centralization of white gorgeous yeah
takes and now the night goes to B for
these sakes don't worry about anything
f5 is dropping this about he's trying to
go nice work no Sam just kind of did
that capture on f5 but a little bit of a
flourish to say what are you doing take
on h7 with a check take on e4 Oh take on
h7 with a check you can't recapture
because e 4 and a eight so you'll have
to move the King oh man your 74 first no
take so that you could take on h7 we're
checking this amazing constructions
we're looking at over there check what's
attractive hold on but really he's
quinny's Queen nasty you gotta take with
the rook and there goes your night but
he looked checkmate
rook check Oh a just take them tonight
okay okay this is completely unique of
course is over there's no point to this
you can take whatever you like give us
the b-pawn you had nothing left you got
Bishop and 92 points you right this is
all prayer this is over let's find a
competitor okay and Sam is coming back
with a vengeance nicely done
salmon Wesley so David devar David been
on a bit of a roll Jennifer yeah
look at this move five five okay there's
some intention no question about it okay
and
captured with the EEP yeah he needed to
keep that Jeep on Flavia absolutely that
rooks are doubled on the G file no G
takes f five but now what was Wesley's
move and he's a sorry
we were waiting his plate looking attack
and some issues with it right and then
if you take back with the pawn Knight
takes c6 and queen if it would be made
complicated variations and he only has
17 SEC 16 ticking down nervous as ever
my view is David Nabarro
move I'm looking at Queen FA check and
said how am I gonna deal with that
Knight g8 and Sam Shanklin has one guys
not a surprise he's just he was but he's
coming back like a boss Queen f8 asking
a very salient no but you can't move the
knight is pinned oh I beg your pardon
now Queen h7 now you have 907 again it's
no longer pin exactly that and just king
h3 just sidestepping okay takes and now
Queen eight seven he was just trying to
get some moves in there but even work f6
looks good here
Wow well kudos to David I thought that
was gonna have to be a resignation he
just found a way to stay alive
yeah but rook f6 looks really
unfortunately too strong that's what
happy powerful and we can keep eating
with rook takes f5 your idea 93 played
take take the pawns and rook g5 pile
lean up against the pin night okay and
once again I think we saw a flag I think
we saw a flag we just let's go back to
Fabi hurry Christian I can't five you
make it six in a row I don't know you
should go too
I think you should go to knock is
winning but he does have some place in
the position only five seconds as he's
trying to push his pawns on the board
now just trying to win a piece no come
on I won the piece I'm gonna win the
piece back sorry but he doesn't he's
back he could have won that piece but
he's decided to keep the extra material
but can he can he ever win the piece
back and now he's only got six seconds
now he's only gonna make a droid looks
like look at that two seconds exactly or
lose no wait
oh my gosh trouble now big time trouble
and now he's g6 pawn is actually wide
hanging oh one second okay now it's a
recognition pending the pawns are
dropping like crazy right put that
bottom b3 and defended you defend it
quickly yes and the King cannot attack
it so King sees no are we there okay
well we can't be increment he's having
trouble with that and I called a match
between Hikaru and Magnus where there
was rook and Bishop versus rook but
Hikaru one with the rook the one on time
all right the white keep checking their
magnus carlsen oslo right he doesn't
want to check for some reason Oh getting
behind the piece well just to make them
but he can't don't you can't push push
gotta move oh no but rook G
he's got to defend this endgame okay
there's still a draw
famous rook and Bishop versus rook
endings oh you can't blame Luke takes
because of rook b2 so he's just played
but this wasn't one of the three and now
checks are gonna chase your king around
okay in another check and oh the another
check you got to watch what you can do
is ship D but then King King to be to
okay and you're back in this second rank
if okay oh no he's getting into he's
still okay for now but this is a kind of
in game you know you guys like h1 rook
b1 always bloating he's blown ok Hikaru
Nakamura boy did he Carter turn that
game around
you look yeah get the draw he said no I
want to try to win and look what we have
a draw for hurry not an ownership 23 and
a half points is Fabiano as he's one
point from match victory Jennifer oh
gosh good call yeah if Bobby wins this
game he will win the showdown against
Harry Krishna with a whole day and some
does the air right so that's a big one
and dominguez vessel intifada that match
a little bit closer than the other
yeah absolutely Hikaru is making some
distance now with a four and a half one
and a half but score over due to linear
in the Blitz two and a half versus three
now Veselin Topalov playing consistently
good chess but Sam Shanklin you know
gaining some respect after I had
terrible outing in the wrap
Jennifer amarice over to you you have a
a moment for Duda in the Sun here well
it's what happens and the the quick
blitz players the players whose brains
that seem to work on overdrive when it
comes to blitz they spot tactics like
that and in this position dude I had
such a great game and now this pawn is
White's main source of counter play you
see this pawn say that's guy that guy's
got to die so ninety seven just fork the
rook and the pawn simple if you try to
defend it I'm just gonna attack it just
give the pawn over that pawn is gone and
then you're gonna be trying to force a
draw and if you decided after ninety
seven let's play this move work b7 and
I'm gonna get your pawn and maybe get
the g6 pawn as well maybe he was worried
about that no you got to see these
things in the blink of an eye rook takes
you for Queen takes and I mean King
takes a knight takes on c5 check and
you're done
these are the little tactics you have to
see in blitz him to see them quickly
guys like Nakamura see this just for
breakfast and here this was his own
moment when he had coming up yes and
here he is Knight check and here he
could play that move Knight to d7 97 the
knight on c4 and instead of dealing with
that pawn there you saw activity and you
see him now suffering in this position
as the pawn stayed alive you see that
critical move rook to c7 and now the
pawn going down the board and this was
his pawn become a source of counter play
this when he panicked against it and
Nakamura made this pawn useful and
that's why we saw the rest of the game
proceed the way it did
Wow really those tactics and I hear you
loud and clear those blink of an eye and
I remember playing a lot of blitz games
with Garry Kasparov and having the
feeling that like seeing those tactics
so easily and there we saw a young Duda
being outplayed by the wily veteran but
I think dude is just going to get better
and better check so Bobby
Harry Krishna I just put a positive spin
on it if he wins 18 and games are all I
think every single game
you couldn't win the match that's right
there we go
he's not out of it yet yeah
theoretically theoretically yeah I could
do something we the likes of witches
you've never seen and yeah okay but I
would really like to see hurry get of
the tree but what game guys which game
would we like to go can we go back to do
that because that match somehow is still
drawing her I don't know why you guys
are looking at it dude about losing we
came back to the position late in the
game we we should we have other two best
chance the guy's not playing at the top
of his game right now I think I'm going
to look for now okay I don't think we're
seeing the best chess on this one
Nakamura is just pasting him well oh no
I don't think the best ever
I mean the best chance of the showdown
because you know Nakamura is so good it
quits oh you mean you want to see him
get in keep beating the guy obviously
the comeback of Shanklin by the way I
think that would be fun and and Wesley
and we should give Wesley we should give
Wesley and Navarro some play both we
should look at place with the white
pieces it seems of the game the opening
stage tends to be a little bit more
interesting as far as many of our fans
are concerned exactly a lot of the ones
where we're not as white between the
queens get trader early right right
right
they're going in for that same variation
a few times so the one into the
beginning last time well it's like both
players are very willing to play chaotic
positions right even this exact position
that they have is also a very uneven
looks like another English with
c5 takes d4 oh yeah yeah yeah it's got a
different character than some of the
battles that they've played for sure
exactly with this wedge from c3 to e5
now who do you like playing in these
positions
you know I've always found it easier to
play white these English variations
because basically as white I know what
I'm doing I'm playing from Nate you know
going after your King because your king
blacks King is missing an f7 pawn so I'm
gonna put my knight on the e3 I'm gonna
put my Bishop on g4 or f3 I'm gonna put
my rook on b5 and what you're going for
the qinger you're going for my deep on
deep on first King next sac the defund
then we sack the King and there he is
going for it right right now the point
is I'm gonna have to face the music of
your Queen side majority one day that
that day is twenty moves from now in the
meanwhile I'm gonna have a lot of fun
over here as white may be playing for f4
f5 again may be playing for Bishop g4
Bishop f3 97 and this is also one extra
move I can kind of try to sneak in so
again I'm just saying it's easier in my
view to play the white side and here by
the way it starts to think about how
could I occupy e5 94/95 should I preface
it with that for Bishop a3 nope no just
pressure the pawn right away absolutely
so a 6g - exactly Park the bishop back
on G to keep that d5 now play that for
as he's an eyeballing an opportunity to
play for 94-95 oh yeah always
what does blacks plan he's trying to
play d5 and before precisely there we
have it yeah has he played before has
played behind
okay so again I know I'm gonna have to
face your majority on the Queen side one
day but before that day
usually I get to have a lot of fun on
the kingside 5 another board
f5 Bishop f7 oh my he once again they
chief Warren but at the moment rook
takes out 500 do I play Queen c2 as a
pre-processing a preface signal he's
thinking on b5 first okay fair enough
getting rid of an isolated pawn over
there maybe a B and now don't forget
that perhaps the rook could land on a 1
at some point Queen c2 and then an
immediate h5 played by now yeah no no no
that would have been really really an
awkward move to face what about three or
use playing well h5 is h5 is protected
the bishop on f7 does you know protect
Department I'm thinking by the way okay
King H 1 and then Queen d7 played okay
players are really moving quickly
especially Nakamura and Nakamura with a
30 second time it can be very
significant in blitz work after two
played I'm not sure Nakamura looks
confused as well as yeah like quite some
time before finally playing rook aid
think about Nakamura is he's an 85 90
percent or even 80 85 percent play are
80 to 90 if you will consistent moves he
says you know what I'm not gonna find
the best to move in the position I'm
gonna find a good enough woman if it's
not a blunder then I'm gonna just play
it and that's how he saves time in the
clock
it's when he's the last two moves have
been extra long thinks and this is when
he gets into some kind of trouble but
you'll see him start flashing those
moves very quickly as he knew he had a
big decision to make here
he decided to play this move b4 and
that's got his opponent digging into the
time situation well thinking because
something's gonna land on a4
well I think it's time to go g3 g4
for Duda oh he's and Nakamura
as though he didn't do anything at all
he found this move be three if you take
it then he takes on c4 that's with tempo
a wildly move but but you just drop it
driving back to be one back to b1 and b2
is coming this exchange for this pawn on
b3 did he do this on purpose no it was
94 he's surely missed 90 95 95 okay that
look like a true sacrifice though this
is g5 making lemonade out of lemons
there you go
Queenie for Bishop f8 played as a 7 his
knights eat instead of Queenie for I
instead of Queenie for I thought Bishop
g5 was a winner guy no bishop Queen I
should now no he didn't play that he
played King g1 okay he's anticipating
anticipating that the bishop is gonna be
harassed and he may have to play Bishop
takes d5 so he didn't want to see his
King okay so Richard has for me
Duda has an exchange and a pond
am i counting that right yes exchange
and upon any threatening f7 f6 some of
that Bishop those blockading very well
that was why Bishop f7 was important
otherwise upon would have been on f7 as
we speak okay is that beep on going
anywhere it looks like the answer is no
but how does we might make progress is
rooks at the league Queen DF file Queen
a8 no Queen f3 12 seconds is he's I'm
stroking it on the increment yes lucky
leave the F file I mean looks necessary
here but how did he he has to put his
rooks on another farm
well he file a file alright okay the a
file yeah the ephah ooh I've got a I've
got a breaking alert that I don't know
if we beat it's 5 seconds left on dudas
clock 4 3
Bobby's gonna win his game in the
measured I think was a foregone
conclusion that he was going to win that
match and I don't if we were really
surprised by that yeah not too much
there goes the rooks shifting this is
what I was talking about important now
where do the routes belong eh maybe
worse and offer up a trade for seconds
rook takes always allowed an a pawn no
he Carl recaptured with the pawn how
weird was yeah we pardon me with the
Queen how weird was that this is weird
knockos wheelhouse this is an h3 as you
somehow na kids are staying here and
keeping the edge on the clock now the
king is going to h2 the rook and finally
but how does it penetrate no squares in
blacks position okay but can we play all
nasty h4 I was about to say rook to b5
and Bishop f4 oh no look at this
Nakamura now trying to get his pawn one
step further he's done it and Queen was
look for the pony suddenly Nakamura mami
nice winning
knows he's got him I'm Bishop d5
Nakamura is gonna play well first
guarding that pawn okay Queen f3
stopping Bishop d5 between but this is
over right he knows it's over Bishop is
gonna come into the game sooner or later
and it's going to come with a fact check
get back to the back row how does he get
the dark square bishop to work though
that's what Nakamura is trying to figure
out been waiting for a blunder by the
way I'm waiting for a blender you know
sooner or later the guys gonna make a
mistake in this position it's three
seconds your time is horrific here comes
that bishop where do you put the Queen
offering a queen trade when you lose the
Jeep on whoa that was making it rather
easy okay now he's gonna look for some
kind of counter play Oh Nakamura allowed
King D 400 you'll be able to play bishop
he's gonna play Bishop F 1 but Bishop F
1 this
the pawn and then he wants to go King G
a king f7 crucial to get this blockading
yeah okay it is when it is winning it
out of the way right second not about
here comes that Bishop not more a boss
technique once again who does he kill
here does he take the D pawn of course
yeah he's gonna be looks long again in a
second right and he's got his king up oh
he stopped no getting that but the
bishop was gonna go into the back door I
went to his King King e6 and that
followed by Bishop e5 reverse am
Shanklin still under a salmon well yeah
it's called some sam-i-am US Champion to
do I had to pick his opponent right to
win the Blitz for Sam to say wherever
you picked me to win the whole match the
battle wind got upset and said boom he's
getting hard getting some respect
getting some respect David oh by the way
Sam's board is a crazy apparently the
end of his game
this is the video replay he was lost on
the clock and he also knocked over the
power and so he just said look you for
decisive games and this is the seventh
round Jennifer as we've got Nakamura
victorious Fabiano Carolyn ah so on
David navara and Sam Shanklin both on
the comeback trail as the match between
is being is
the polyp retains topple up in the lead
by getting a little closer today
not really this little pose from the
last year outs but we have a tournament
winner already yet winner as Paul
Di'Anno Kurata has now clinched the
match against Harry Krishna
he's got $36,000 in the bag and
boatloads of raiding points in both the
Blitz and the rapid and now of course
they're gonna continue to play their
games by no chance for Harry Krishna
Queen or tie this mess and 36,000
dollars richer it's fabulous Karl I
can't believe Kimura is doing two Duda
the silver medalist big game well the
games seem like this close this movie
wasn't close hey Gouda Duda was even
winning that game right he's up in
exchange he just had to do the right
things with his rooks all of a sudden he
traded off these rooks and suddenly the
pawn on beat three turned into a monster
and then it turned into a queen
literally and I mean the way he the way
he handles it's like who's better in the
last 20 seconds that's what I've noticed
who's better in the last 20 seconds
Nakamura in the last 20 seconds with a
two minute to second increment you're
unbelievable yep give me even ten
seconds give me ten seconds we're a
two-second increment Nakamura makes it
looks like two hours I mean just instant
instant and he's like this all the time
and like I said he could probably do
commentary Wow oh yeah that as well what
kind of begs the question is NOK more
even better at match play blitz as he is
in for instance around Robin tape lifts
or switz blitz and I would say yes
because he has so much experience and
those you know all night blitz matches
on chess calm exactly and so maybe
that's part of the reason that this is
so lopsided
his training has been phenomenal and his
understanding of psychology and momentum
and all those factors yeah yeah it
doesn't hurt that he's played guys like
Magnus all those matches they play those
he's he's saying to himself look dude I
know you're young but coming up but you
know I played the best
I played Magnus Carlsen who are you
right it's like if if somebody said I
play one-on-one against LeBron
you're not gonna do anything more
dangerous than that guy right that's
what he's showing now he's so calm it's
like he's not ruffled at all and he it's
almost as though he knew he would
dominate doing right we've got a few
extra minutes Jen but I think we have a
special to share with our audience
that's that's right the players are
asked about what they feel about seat
Louis being a mecca of chess in the
world not only the capital of the United
States but garry kasparov said a center
of gravity in the chess world
what do you think the city of st. Louis
means to the International chess stage
but each year it becomes more and more
prominent to the Grantchester is
expanding there's so many more
international events bringing players
from all over the world top players st.
Louis has become for sure the capital of
chess in the world
maybe not the rock capital of chess but
one of the capitals I guess I mean
together with probably Moscow and some
other place it's very strong mmm
I thought of such a city so I'm happy
I'm here when you hear some voice you
kind of at least I think our chess it's
really great what what some louise has
become purchase I see a lot of chess
activity a lot of events lot of kids
playing here so it's wonderful here
there are many really interesting events
Grantchester is quite a nice idea I was
following the Kent's Cup among other
tournaments but also many others
championship us ownership but mainly the
same full cup these days where all the
top players are impeding beyond that
there are also a lot of European players
who try to play the norm tournaments as
well and just in general it's a great
atmosphere and it's great to see all the
things that have happened here in st.
Louis over the last 10 years I guess 10
or 11 years Rex and do you think they'll
have really been a lot of support Jeff
here
it's the thirst of in the support of
where great American chess players come
if the only reason why American chess is
booming right now any tournament you
play in Europe wherever it is people
have heard about the Chess Club ins
classic Center in st. Louis this is my
very first time in st. Louis but of
course I was watching many of the
tournaments and events taking place here
just when I got this tool you know
looking around the place a little bit I
was very familiar with Michael I believe
that people are getting to know Santos
and getting to respect the efforts in
st. Louis is absolutely set an example
for what chest should be all over the
world will be you guys have both hosted
the best tournaments in the world as
well as put chess as far as I know into
every single school in the st. Louis
area and this
as a dream come true for a chess player
of any level be a professional or
someone who just enjoys the game and I
think the rest of all would be do a
great job with all st. Louis example
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about after the game heading back
to the hotel would be a major error
instead
boogie through the city and discover the
music that gave the Blues their name at
the National Blues Museum Broadway
Oyster Bar or even the legendary
Blueberry Hill so whether you love the
Cardinals the Blues or the Blues come
play with us you guys know I can't play
this right st. Loup is always exploring
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together
the world chess Hall of Fame mind art
experience
[Music]
the Kings here at the st. Louis chess
club in the capital of chess in the
United States says you have ten
fantastic chess players from all over
the world playing here and twenty five
playing under the United States flag
it's been a real treat Jennifer watching
these kings of the chessboard dueling it
out lots and lots of stories lots of
games to watch we're gonna turn our
spotlight to the game of Wesley so and
David navara as those two players have
really been taking the measure of one
another as well that's right today
actually
anavar is ahead by a couple of points as
he's been scoring something that we did
not expect I mean Wesley so has a very
very deserved reputation as we know from
his the grand chest or what a great
rapid what specialist he is and pretty
darn good blitz player but David navara
has been doing very well thus far for
victories so far in the match for navara
- for Wesley so as we're in round eight
so I don't know about you guys I'm
thinking there's gonna be another
decisive game here and look at him go I
mean the players are playing all of
these moves and I dunno its theory but
it's remarkable that they've been
playing them just Allah tempo with one
another f7 f5 very important move by
black to get that move in quickly before
that efore pong becomes a real target
and c5 by Wesley now that's a very
intriguing move for me as he's made a
big commitment giving up the d5 square
but he's seeking to play Bishop c4 I do
I do think I just don't know yeah well I
think he has an edge but I just don't
know exactly exactly
to get the Knight to d5 right that's
what I'm thinking I think David went to
that square is just not
yeah David wants to play e5 and then he
wants to go like 9f 896 and bring the
but it's not that easy in fact it's
awkward but I think II five in King e7
have got to be the way to get the show
started
okay this move by the way does threaten
Knight takes c5 so it does kind of gain
a half tempo and force King c3 and move
that white is absolutely going to play
90% of the time regardless of whether
you play book t8 or not
now we right I didn't Castle queenside
no because somehow I like the King on e7
there maybe there's a pawn storm that
would happen yeah and here well this is
some hype preparation by Wesley because
he could have saved this not for a blitz
match but for a real classical opponent
he's doing something really remarkable
with this whole strategy now if I'm
David I'm capturing on e5 and I'm
playing yep on d4 pardon me and I'm
playing 9 f8 because I'm desperate to
get my knight to a good square and E 6
will attack the d4 pawn that's a big
deal and that's a big deal I really
would like to be able to attack that
each pawn on h4 as well at the time yeah
we got to wait for that to happen you
never had the time the night however
like f4 now yeah thank you six and then
get that d5 nut I'm thinking f2 f3 White
has got to break up the team over there
that black has so are you thinking f3
but if F what do you do after 96 I take
on he decided he decided this
breakthrough has given him a majority on
the Queen side and the ship takes with
that Bishop this could be challenging
and to be six or yeah b7 b6 you can take
and go c6 but then I'll play b5 so you
don't get a protected pass pawn pink b6
has gotta be 7
this is my thought was but then you take
on the e6 and take on d7 and white will
get the D file no but you got the what
about your age for pawn all the time
though no up there hey you were
absolutely right
although he is going down this path and
you could take on geese d1 or you could
have taken on d1 and then force the
defense I think oh he's got rooked d6
check correct
he's got d1 so you know King has to go
maybe to e7 so that after rook t6 rook
h4 rook g6 king f7 I think he so this is
I think that he'll survive this although
he's got to win the F pawn so that his
epon wakes up and Jennifer what's the
time because I see nervous or is that
asking for trouble trying to put your
eye like that - faith behind your own
past so the thing is though that you
give him these play Kings have the most
passive of all of them of all the
choices he's now the Jeep on will be
passed that rook f4 and he will get his
F pawn past and you actually get two
connected passers well that's why he
analyzed oh not look takes g7 but b5
alright here we go
okay king is forced to go to the back
rank where that G pawn will become a
force White's King is gonna go King d4
King e5 to keep the black passers
well not in check but it's not gonna be
easy though blockaded and he's trying to
pick up which squirrel is better here
King c8
I wouldn't be arguing with myself over
King b8 or King see it I just played
very quickly yeah yeah yeah it's hard to
figure out why one would be better than
the other in here okay g6 g7 is the big
problem right that's I play a lot of
giving
five rookie five is a good start what do
you think Jen can wait win this got the
extra pawns I think he's gonna win this
yeah yeah I do too Wesley looks very
very confident here but guys I'm gonna
call this and I'm gonna say Wesley is
gonna win well Dominguez is also very
interesting okay what would you like
domingus let's do it Dominguez it is
I've got Dominguez up on my board and
Lanier is white laughs whoo Veselin is
just hit back with the move c7 c5
striking against the knight on c6 e six
that's a break take the knight take on
c5 yeah yeah taketake this looks like
it's got to be good for whites I'm just
slight square attacking opportunities
like oh no oh no now I can't get it on
eight seven I can't say I like the way
he transformed this one now it's back in
business for black black it's fine too
connected passed pawns blockading the
deep on this is okay for black there's
no mate ever a linear missed an
opportunity there was it a golden
opportunity 10 20 seconds for each
player yes we owe Queen d6 was that
necessary
why not Queen d4 if you learn it by the
way Fabiano is mating Harry Krishna in
his game so that one is done it's done
Oh No yes reporter Shanklin all right
let's do that because this game looks
like it's going to be a draw bit okay
I'd rather play white and have to pawn
I've got the game of Sam Shanklin
against Richard and again two knights as
you were saying your sister
to stop the deep on so I'm not sure this
one is nearly as bad it's the one that
we looked at with naka and we're and has
just captured the Queen site there is no
black Queen site anymore and technically
speaking this is a draw but I had this
is too shy don't know about that with Ty
and those tricky nights
there's also trades and blitz
liquidation opportunity of this next
night followed by Bishop days before
right I think he did well there was a
night check maybe 95 check to recapture
over the night on d3 what's this he's
taken what happened there oh there's a
95 check thready you have to worry about
this right and now let's go to Nakamura
doo-dah cuz I can't still underway Duda
it's got the extra pawn but can he make
anything out of it look at that yes
oh that's huge Carl will have to use all
of his defensive resources to save this
one rook to c2 okay you must have
thought it was losing so far it's darn
good for Duda is what it is yeah did I
just say what I think that's a darn good
this is drawn whoa what was that wait
wait wait a second he grabbed the Queen
right there Mora trying to find a way it
way but another check and he's got a
repeat and he doesn't see away now you
guys might rook hg1 yes knock a more
even
dead looking at giving us some thrills
at the very end and Duda has the feeling
that he missed the breakthrough was
right g4 was a draw g5 but it was a
great many lesser player absolutely oh
my goodness wow dude it was doing it was
winning that game earlier by the way as
expected but you say that Duda was
winning at a certain moment I want to
give you a position in you to you tell
me okay
take a look this is move 39 after-work
f1 okay black as three pawns on this
side pawn well defended white with no
shred of counter play he's defending
yeah and it's just that guy right
straight pawn time to try to win the
game of course you're playing Nakamura
so we're gonna play some great technique
he played this move one passive move
rook a one rook c5 oops
bye-bye pawn and the rest we saw happen
he was able to win this pawn but this
one was not as strong as this one as the
pieces liquidated down and we saw that
endgame where he was not able to win
I'm sorry Maurice is that the whole
story there after king h6 you can't take
on a5 right king h6 because a bishop
takes e4 at the end maybe do this too
well alright but let's go go up to
Christian and Nakamura up in the game
thanks guys I'm here with Hikaru
Nakamura after a dominating performance
Hikaru congratulations up to this point
you seem to be playing a very very good
chess so take us through this section
well first of all congratulations is a
little bit premature there's still quite
a few games left nonetheless yeah I
played pretty well so far
and even the positions where I've been
in trouble they've been messy and
complicated so um yeah I've today's or
not today's I'm sorry this last game I
was probably slightly worse the whole
way it was never really that bad I think
perhaps the end I made a little a little
bit more dramatic than I needed to with
this whole this work component game but
nonetheless I mean the goal is really
just to try and avoid losing and just
you know burnt burn the games that are
lost until you win the match but
obviously young Kristoff hasn't hasn't
been great today I mean he's had he's
had some good positions but I think he's
just been a little bit too tilty he's
gotten he sort of when he's lost in
these games have been very messy it just
seems to fall apart in the next one so
I'm just he needs to be a little bit
more salt perhaps would you say your
momentum is the biggest factor of
playing in this matches yeah I mean in
three plus two expecially you're gonna
have a lot of decisive games so if you
got off to a good start
and when the first first one or first
couple generally it's that's a good
trend and I know like in the grand
chester when i played here I think the
rapid and the blitz every single day I
lost the first game so I was able to
recover from that but certainly you
don't want to start off with losses
because then it just adds more pressure
and sort of the negativity built so it's
very important to get off to a good
start and keep the momentum in your
favor what do you think of the overall
format of these matches and would you
like to see any changes um I mean
perhaps some of the matches could be
more competitive but in general I think
the format is quite good so twelve rapid
games gives you a chance sort of to
prepare quite a bit with the white piece
doesn't come up with some ideas and and
therefore I think it makes for very
interesting chess I mean I think so are
the results and the matches haven't been
really great per se but I still think
the format itself is really good and at
least in my match we've played some very
interesting openings and so I'm pretty
pleased with the experience that I've
gained excellent thank you very much
Chicago and good luck in the rest of
your games thank guys well we'll take
this one that has not been such a good
format for Hari Krishna at least for us
watching we'd love to be able to watch
far beyond Caruana
play all his games or at least a bunch
of games but his match is so one-sided
he already won we
got a day and a third to go but this
game it just signifies just how badly
he's been beating on his opponent in
this position with pure confidence after
his opponent played a little unorthodox
open this pawn this square looks well
covered I mean you got a knight two
pawns that's where you would think
nobody's going anywhere near mm-hmm
except probably said boom let me play c5
anyway so that I could just put my
Bishop on b5 now I got a nice Bishop
sitting right there threatening Knight
takes f6 oh thanks for all those like
squares weaknesses let me shift my queen
over in that general direction
well maybe a move like h5 or a queen
appearing instead he tries to develop
his night and Fabi said oh quickly
Knight takes on e5 a boss move Queen to
h5 check flusher King over this way
Bishop takes g5 and now you can't
capture back because the rook is hanging
he staggered with this move only to get
met by a basic exchange and then check
and there went his Knight and he no
longer was a sacrifice as he was winning
back his piece and this king after f4
just got murdered in its own bed this
has been a whitewash guys this complete
demolition by the number two player on
the planet
beautiful beautiful game there nice
combination by Faviana when it rains it
pours Jennifer and we're gonna take a
quick commercial break jazz but guys
look forward to the last third of the
blitz games and a lot games for more
games to go over and it's gonna be
really fun so join us in a few minutes
for champions showdown blitz time
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online - more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the Chess Club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week directly across the
street from the Chess Club is the world
chess Hall of Fame this one-of-a-kind
cultural institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and here are our standings in the
champions showdown the Kings as we have
Nakamura with a 14 point 20 a total of
20 and Judah with 12 we've got twenty
five and a half out of Carolina that's
the only player who's already clinched
his match in deep and meanwhile Wesley
and a Veselin Topalov both on 19 and a
half researcher for the closest to
clinching victory with 21 he needs to
win three and a half out of four of the
last four games but this match has been
pretty tight in the blitz yet it has
there's been some a lot of
back-and-forth dude has been in a lot of
the games with the Cara buddy Carlos
keeps running up the score as somehow he
gets that extra half a point here and
there whether it's an emission versus
rook ending or well and saving those
palm down rook endings and the players
are quickly repeating the same line
Maurice you realize that this guy is the
silver medalist in the world blitz it's
amazing I was making him look like and
random average run-of-the-mill player
and he is not this young man young Duda
from Poland is the real deal he's going
to be really one of the superstars of
tomorrow if not today 20 years old
create yeah but not today let me just
clarify I'm not today okay and here we
go a repeat of their previous outing him
like I said like white because this King
side majority F for g4 let's have some
fun
yeah pushing baby right out of the gate
you bet and look at him go this is what
I was talking about in the first time
they played this opening yeah one day
one day Black has the Queen side but
before that time white gets to have a
lot of fun
push him f5 there's the hesitation when
you're playing against knock'em
it's just amazing you need all of those
extra precious seconds that you can ever
have and Wow well this game really has
exploded with huge majorities now for
both players its Queen b6 Czech Queen
III some idea is there for Nakamura but
this night c4 I don't know
Bishop c5 check this you might have a
pawn storm I got a monster but that king
you got to always take a long look at it
because it's settled there he was
checking to see where he should put his
king right the pawn storm is on for sure
but they're no pieces necessarily
supporting it just yet so blacks not
worried about that black is gonna look
for his counter play before this pawn
these pawns really hit home well they're
they're about to hit home though Maresa
I was about to say that Knights gonna
come to f3 now the knight has the option
of jumping to e4 j maybe 94 Bishop c6
Bishop c4 on the board and by the way
that just yeah well it does remember 94
Bishop c6 Bishop f3
that looks good for white right you sure
remember Knight B 3 will be a move as
well + u c3 pawn is under fire and was a
lot of and you know me I walked through
the Gobi Desert barefoot for a pawn
Knight takes e4 Bishop c6 check King g3
if I'm feeling rambunctious a lot of
options here for Duda too many options
as his clock is ticking down he's played
their conservative Murray immediately
yeah I like this choice how about you
Jed very solid does a lot of different
things it wants to fence 94 okay you
know that's a transposition to the line
we started with with 94 that was a first
choice it was an extra branch I didn't
think it worked but this one gives gives
Nakamura a few more options perhaps they
thought exactly by the way Bishop g5 is
developing with tempo so something to
keep in mind Bishop takes e4 to bishops
Oh huge majority now
for black but there's queen defy check
that's got to be game over queen defy
check forces the trade of queens and
then I'm thinking wow how could he not
like Wendy five Jack okay which is okay
okay still in the air though absolutely
as is ecigs and Bishop e5 but maybe this
gives knocking a chance to play Knight
b3 Bishop D for Bishop d4 yeah I would
have liked Queen d5 Bishop d4 ok 93 he's
making room against Knight b3 for work
on a 1v1 that's a good choice agree
checking grab the bishop yep yep exactly
nice point
very nice point you and rook d1 will
threaten Bishop t5 right now on an aryan
queen leaping to a follow what's that
that's c4 pawn alert Bishop defy check
take c4 mmm
then you've got C - I'll take on deep on
b3 by the way engines giving f6 as
winning cold wouldn't doubt it that's f6
on winning attack by the way what is
defending black scheme at 62 you're
playing well I've got Bishop on e4
so C - I've got covered and he's played
it by the way cold blooded the point is
if you take Bishop eight seven check
rips apart your King followed by Queen
takes b7 check and the attack crashes
through a bishop will land on h6 and
your King has no protection and what to
do he has taken and now if he finds the
bishop eight seven check Nakamura will
have to move his King away does he see
it he did not see it he didn't
not see the main crushing point but it's
still hovering in the position these
ideas but why can't Bishop takes on f6
now I thought he was gonna go Bishop h6
immediately
rook takes f6 rook takes f6 Bishop d5
check is on the board
he still has Bishop h7 check but you had
there's a base 7 check cuz you couldn't
say because of Queen b7 e7 checking g7
but this line also still six Jack we
always have to check those lines right
Queen needs to get in the game Clinton
84 is winning in that position takes as
well but he's taken logically on c4 they
can by the way Queen 7 and the night
bingo Queen takes how can you resist
when you see a tactic like that well
Nakamura's gonna play rook f8 because he
sees Queen b7 Queen b3 there'll be a
bishop but now what about hanging on f4
so Queen b7 check the King has to drop
back you just take him the knight simple
chess yeah show me show me what you got
of a piece sense and ain't [ __ ] time
something we have been able to say at
all this one's totally winning and now
mark Nakamura is going into trick mode
he's hoping that his opponent will miss
some ideas win the game rook before is
he gonna take one in for it does that
work hard to believe no there'll be a
queen bee a check at the end of the day
and now queen c3 is last gasp is
nakamura with the Bishop e5 bit
hikaru he Cara didn't even want to wait
for Bishop e5 you just gave it up and
said okay I got it I got ya let's let's
jump to the Sam Shanklin game Jennifer
what's happening what's happening well
it's over is what's happening
to make a specimen let's get into that
game one of our closest matches we've
seen so many matches that have not been
competitive but a lot of them are close
within the blitz competition oh come on
is losing whoa taking a little bit a
little bit for Hari there I mean he's
had such bad luck and what is going on
that's lent opal off numerous prominent
linear is just wow being left and right
he could resign this position with a
clear conscience no question about it
four seconds left on his clock and down
three pawns all of those pawns are just
pawns just go defending everything he's
just moving off momentum right exactly
cuz that pawn is the ratio day six put
your king in the corner and now ya
weight is coming that's right it's not a
movie wanted to have happen right and
now a check discovery the old painful
discovered check oh that's an oldie but
a goodie and Fabio loses game alright
well let's just take a look at Fabio
because I mean Hari has not had many
moments of the Sun here and let's give
him a chance to shine with a Royal fork
at the end Jennifer look at that final
position as the night on f8 hits the
King on g6 check and the Queen on d7
Fabi did not have nine lives as it's
okay Harry Krishna the ninth game to
score a victory but he did it that was
very clever little short on my job tell
us what happened
Maurice I'm not gonna tell you look like
Sam manages draw okay other than that we
saw a big deal is
Wesley Wesley one toe to toe in our
blitz you're the only ones that you can
say about that Dominguez and those
Chaplin matches are also relatively
close but it's actually shank Linden
Beslan who are both doing well and the
soda varna okay let's let's repeat the
rare moment that Hari Krishna got his
night to fork it was oh well not Harry
when Harry saw that f/8 square he just
like you could almost sense the relief
I've won a game worries do you remember
that trick that's rapport pulled on Sam
the night II a 98 Queen Laurie check
that's right Queen a check nightie a
check the night on the back rank this is
the kind of move that world-class
players will miss that when a knight
appears on a square that it normally
just simply does not belong right what's
your night game there your mind won't
even notice the move and so he played
King g6 just blissfully unaware of this
night F a fork that won the game so
those kind of moves look out for nights
on the back row could be extremely
dangerous and sneaky how do you like me
now well six points I got six points I
might not be doing great yes but like to
see who's gonna work
this order of accuracy here well party
with the word come on shout out to
Christian gold medalist look at that pic
that he has well the Dallas Cowboys
alright wait a minute wait a minute
let's not go with all the holy of holies
beloved Dallas Cowboys America's Team
you know like hello hello yeah that's
true
you have been consistent we'll give you
that this man who's already confirmed
participation magnus carlsen our world
champion our number one player in the
world and also has some pretty cool
bosses in that job no question about it
there's everybody on tour this year not
including of course the wild cards
jennifer well big welcome to dig Moran
of China yes he doing new for 2019 we
also are really excited to have some of
our faves back are American big three
not your Carolina Leslie so and we have
new countries as well starting off in
Coto evoi and that's gonna be May 6 2011
something you've been thumping the table
quarter yeah I love it
Oh Asia thank you so much Zagreb and
then we were going back to our
traditional spots Paris Saint Louis the
crown jewel of Sinquefield Cup in August
this again but then another new event
yes and then we have
in Bucharest Romania and Kolkata India
until the finals which will take down
during the London chessboxing
exactly what a tour it should be yeah I
know actually there is a press release
out explaining which players are playing
with your back more competitors more of
its more wildcards and bigger prize
money
nice that's right one point 1.75 I mean
thank you for the good what's 500 km on
Friday exactly that's what I've always
asked myself and let's pick a game let's
do two just one game yeah well let's
stay I want to see how do knock amor
responds after getting beat cuz here I'm
driving away that was a dominating
performance by Duda I mean he played
boss chest that game that whole f4 g4 f5
what he concocted you don't see noch
amol going down do you do you remember
if Duda has always been in this posture
throughout all the matches this this
thing with his his left hand always
either on his face or how's her head is
he always like this
well it looks like he's worried at every
game divided lane we just I'm so
interesting he I think it's a common
post for him I really do I've seen it
often but I'm wondering if it was from
the very beginning is only when he
started getting beat but did you see
that by the way like the the players are
already deep into the game and he cara
looked up just to say yeah yeah yeah I
prepared this see there this is the kind
of thing I'm talking about right the
body language is something that we do of
course who checking to see how players
feel look a body language around the
room not most people don't do this one
one hand the off hand on your head
somehow as you think about you know how
do you get it - a quick flow when you
when your posture is like this is
curious to me he always has that hand
mmm okay well does he have reason for
worry see this is from yesterday well
this posture is because we just have to
find that one right and by the way
[Music]
that's what Bobby Fischer said that's
all it takes us good moves um Bobby
Fischer also said you know you need to
know when to punch and you need to know
when to duck in chess and it looks like
at least to me Carlo is getting ready to
punch as the G file has been blasted
open and something to work with over
here yeah I was about to say well the
short answer is no it doesn't that falls
for a trick Bishop takes h7 the bishop
needed to be defended by the Queen the
Queen couldn't capture the bishop and so
he Carlo just snaggle the pond ouch ouch
and now other way every job that he's
favored he's busted his hand has left
his face and it's like okay okay leave
he missed a one mover basically yeah
and now the question is will Hikaru
showed the type of form that dude I just
showed a moment ago just played f3 and
Carla eyeballing Queen c2 to g2 which
has been stopped by the way by this move
Bishop h3 hey Cara was looking to maybe
go after the g7 pawn rook g3 was this
choice interesting I thought f4 f5 was
going to be his choice
g3 okay extra pawn King g8 useful move I
think
Bishop d4 Bishop e5 and I wanting I want
as white to be able to play Bishop to e5
and Queen c3 and being trying to utilize
the double F pawns as a battering ram
the F 4 and F three pawns I want to I
want to put them to use maybe right away
with f5 what do you think about them
apples Jennifer or Bishop e5 Queen f2
the old discovered check threat h6 in
order to cover that exactly okay between
between Sao Paulo and Dominguez - Pato
play this move Bishop a4 I was Bishop
under attack and simply b3 right now
this night is going to feel a lot of
pains there should be five a4 and that's
gonna be a straight piece in the
position if you take well actually it's
not gonna be a piece but after rook
takes this Bishop will move and then you
won't be able to deal with this the
sweep that's coming up against this
position you're gonna get crushed on the
rank and T'Pol off sitting right here
after b3 not knowing what to do because
his position is going to collapse
rapidly looks like Dominguez will take
this game home cleanly he's also ahead
on the clock
alright thank you for the blunder alert
there and back to Carl Carlin nursing an
extra pawn right now dude is trying to
get some chances of his own counter
chances against he cars King he's got
ideas like Queen h6 to a6 a long
oftentimes these long long moves like
Queen a6 from 104 to the other
controlling
your concern yeah exactly stop that and
at the same time keep the black queen
tether to the bishop on h3 that bishop
on h3 is really stands out like a sore
thumb Bishop on H they can't move means
the Queen can't move means how am I
gonna get my counter fly on the Queen
side due to looking at 85 a43
way too slow Jeb wait way too slow
Queen a3 and he says well queena three
starts to be a real threat for white to
that bishop puzzle rush alert that
bishop might just be trapped chat Shaq
King b2 instantly now b3 but all the
business squares on the C file are
protected bishop c3 poor one his game
against Sammy by the way re just hunting
down that dition sorry
richard has won against now four and a
half for Richard and five and a half for
the US Champion Wow okay but Richard as
we know dominating performance in the
rapid chess he's closing in on match
victory yeah you won't do it today but
you could do it early tomorrow and which
also narrows believe that Beslan had in
the black there's also at three and a
half to five and a half and now it will
be four and a half five and a half and
those two plaits matches or anyone's
game exactly
Hikaru is just playing like a boss this
game boy talk about a comeback
as he carros did hunt down and captured
that bishop and now with the move Queen
g2 oh there's a rook C to check trick
that he's worried about because how do
you stop rook C to check did that work
hmm
whoa I think do to miss know the shot
because you're Cui's hanging so Bishop
takes Dan I trade Queens and the rook
takes never goes back to g1 and the rook
goes back to g1 thank you very sadly
cobwebs Oh
and his crew here on b7 that's with
Chang and that's all she wrote as he
gets his piece back and he's down him he
gets his rook back he's down a piece
he's down on the clock he's got no
counter places staring over there hoping
against hope that somehow he's gonna get
something there's no tricks
you're just eat two kings see threes
pretty awesome looks good your Bishop
gets nowhere he takes righted enough is
enough
not just beating him up youngster well
naca just trading blows because he got
hit pretty much or with the white pieces
so yeah but this shows if you beat him
he's not going to be concerned he's got
no kill that momentum concept exactly
what treaty bones would be a generous
way to describe doodahs performance
today in the blitzes he did women at 4
right I was thinking of just the wins
yeah that's right one I think that yeah
well check them on the screen in a
second but I think you're right I think
it three wins for due to two draws and
then the rest of the wins before
knockout okay and this is our tenth game
so that would be five right yeah and
Fabi bounced back I three two Fabi
bounced back and sadly so Harry Krishna
take a look at this position this is so
sad oh no we've got material parity of
course five pawns five rooks bishop
everything is cool but blacks pieces
look absolutely dominating we like this
night this rook everything on light
squares this Bishop going nowhere
important this is a great position you
can put your queen on c4 now if you want
to just dominate right on the board what
move don't you play with your queen
don't put your queen on pre okay that's
would be too obvious yeah yeah but
almost
he played Queen d3 and don't get
yourself discovered attack check and
there went the queen
oh one move blunder on Thomas from a
dominating position I'm just an over
well
oh that's just that's just not fair that
is the point the point I'll makes you is
when your brains gone it's just gone
when your punch drunk you can't find
moves
this is not something obviously we're
talking out of 2,700 player here exactly
player who once broke into the top ten
in the world in the live ratings at
least this is not stuff he does and so
this is a clear sign that you just you
just can't think anymore
just can't think handle it somehow you
get a great position and how could I
play Queen d3 right so I don't even know
how he recovers I'm sure he's glad
there's only one more game today and
there's only one day left in this
torture that he is going through as he's
just losing every which way you could
lose very dangerous Richard rapport two
points away from clinching 24 and a half
is what's needed we have two more games
to go no it's a potential there is Sam
Shanklin into trouble but okay we do
expect Richard to clinch take us through
it Carla Nakamura
21 that's right 21 points to 13 points
in the meatiness seven to three is he
Karl in the blitz Fabiano eight and of
course he's crashing in the rapid but
and therefore in the total match but in
the blitz they've gone toe to toe with a
couple of drawers and like lots of
decisive games I think
Four Winds refire I don't think we've
seen the best of you linear Dominguez
maybe he's saving it for tomorrow but at
least he's still in this match yeah and
a half for the near Dominguez and five
and a half can you imagine if we started
these matches with blitz they would all
be so much closer except except for
froggies and not good that's awesome
and I think you know we have been
discussing various changes to the format
we're always pushing the envelope here
at club and we're always thinking how
can we bring a better viewing experience
to our viewers and one idea that came up
was why not separate the Blitz and the
rapid who wins rapid who wins blitz
maybe even split the prize money I win
the rapids I get more I win the blood
you in the blitz you get more and then
we combine the scores to see who wins
the overall thing then we've seen here
we would have people fighting like crazy
to win the blitz right and say yeah it's
gonna count and we'd be following three
absolutely wonderful matches at the
moment a matter of fact I would even
argue that even in the matches where
we're seeing them outgunned in those top
two or Fabio's winning easily and knock
is winning easily we might see even
competitive matches there because those
players wouldn't come into today
demoralize exactly potala walked in well
I'm just dead I there's no point to be
playing I can't win but if somebody said
ok you lost the rapid portion would you
come in and you could win the blister
you know what forget about the rapid let
me focus on this part maybe he might
still lose but his spirits would be
higher
coming into today for sure and you might
have given up given a lot more
resistance Thank You Maurice what's your
take on that Jennifer you like that idea
of having three matches and one so to
speak we're gonna play with prize five
separate prize funds separate price ones
for the Blitz and separate price ones
for the overall money that you're
playing for it's not like that but we do
kind of give a shout outs the
Rapids or wins the Blitz overall say in
a Paris or and for to our viewers we
wanted you guys to have the best viewing
experience and just as Hikaru said we
want the matches to be competitive I
think that when there's a match that's
already decided they should ship to like
a dance competition I'm sure you've got
some better ideas judging really well
for that by the way I haven't seen too
many chess boards get out there cutting
a rug do especially when I go to Viva to
go dancing well you guys discussed that
point I'm gonna go with linear and
because that match has been closed as
has the Sam Shanklin match but let's
start with linear and Veselin Topalov
definitely not this is a sharp stuff
this is the rumination variation Venom's
out with an early fianchetto something
that's very happy happily played by get
one garry kasparov did you like this
line for black cast hmm short answer yes
I've found it troublesome let's put it
that way though I I should have been
better theoretically prepared not sure I
like this last move by a couple off I
think Veselin needed to play a 2 a 3
there as the move Queen da to a 5
strikes me as a little bit awkward and
of course he played it did Dominguez
Queen a 5 and then Veselin said you know
what you're right rook D 1 C 1 I'm gonna
take my I'm gonna stutter step with my
rook losing a tempo did
vessel we've got that a very interesting
opening as usual and Nakamura Gouda all
right we're gonna have to use maurices
board for seconds as I'm getting my
mouse getting extra attention okay uh
it's just that well my board is is
definitely fine up here as well so
whenever you're ready we can jump to my
board as they're excellent moving a
piece it looks like this addition of a
three and a repetition foot because
there was a knight c6 move thrown in
tossed in there 296 and III was played
as a parent moves Maurice all right well
let me get also this live board we have
some we have a big live screen here the
master board the master master board and
it looks it looks like a lot of games
going on obviously all five games we
have dominguez this game right here with
the queen drop back to c7 so no
repetition there Caruana
and Hari Krishna in a while Sicilian in
this position this one we have Hikaru
playing against Yann Christophe Duda and
this has been a little bit different
from what they have normally done so far
Sam Shanklin pretty good position and a
past deep on going on in and the Weslie
sold in the vari game as Navarre
actually with the white pieces trying to
make do with his pawn on d6 so very
interesting to see all the games all at
once and a lot of excitement but let's
go back if we can get your PGN yes we're
all good Knights e3 e4 by white Veselin
Topalov
aziz eyeballing the d6 pawn and it's a
it's a kind of a hybrid I want to say
Hedgehog position d7 d6 I've always
liked these positions for black being
able to put my rook on d8 and in this
case the bishop will go to e8 d76 I'm
expecting bi-linear the one thing you
have to watch out for
is that when you play d6 you don't want
to see a knight suddenly appear on the
d5 square when you look is on c1 and
your queen is on c7 so let's see how
this game is unfolded after 94 Jen do we
have a move of linear to having a deep
think it seems he's played to move
Knight a5 and then came rookie 1 and
then came d6 that's right okay so we've
caught up to the players I'm not sure I
understand why the inclusion of the move
Knight a5 was good but that was his
choice now he's he's intending he's
intending simply rook to d8 and then one
day to get this Bishop into the game
neutralized White's spacial as well as
dynamic piece play what's the time it
feel like the players are playing very
slowly is 1 1 minute and 30 seconds for
each so h4 played rook e8 very very good
and the heirs playing this quite well
Knight c3 and again you don't want to
blunder your rook on a 8 right and again
a little bit surprised that this Knight
is stuck on the a5 for the moment rook
do you want to see one as I was saying
you don't want to see at night appearing
on d5 when the rook on the c1 and your
Queen on c7 are lined up full blooded
game just as we're approaching the
one-minute mark we vote for when we
chose this game so linear he's ready for
Bishop b7 Bishop a8 and then he'll very
shortly trust me when I say this he will
have an advantage you can play Bishop e7
bishop a knight be 795 give me black all
day and night 5 the one move I kept
saying you just don't want to see that
move happen
is this good Maurice what the heck is
that that's a piece act isn't it sure
looks like it you got to take it take
take with the pawn Queen d7 what's the
follow-up
is the follow-up for tuple of what is
gonna be before the night's gonna be
trapped oh this is Duke Bonnie five
golly I didn't like that night on any
fine nice move simply have to well he
just like be six oh no I'm not a big fan
of bad choice wait a minute that that
didn't sit well with me he's gotta go
Queen c7 where else is the queen gonna
go always thinking about Queen e8 really
Queenie a mmm I don't know
I think that this was a big miss by what
a weird sequence and he burned somebody
the clock as well somebody's gonna
repeat and go back to c7 he sure that
was just not a ton of sense why not why
not just give the guys peace back it was
a piece sack exactly now he's taking it
and lost the beat pawn as well like made
no sense let me toss this into the okay
and away they went okay still honestly
five so I wasn't that bad linear a super
cool customer truly Wow Fabiana looks
good finest performance I've seen by I
mean since the streak let's make it
clear this is just I remember one other
truly outstanding performance it was our
world champion Magnus Carlsen against
ding Laren here in st. Louis remember
that at showdown match where Magnus
Carlsen absolutely dominated the great
Chinese champion Bingley I do remember
the score but I know it wasn't pretty
it was not pretty yeah okay Veselin
Topalov choice sorry I was just gonna do
a quick search I'll be honest oh that's
a crazy position he was able to get this
moving yeah okay yeah that was okay
that's that's that game is getting
definitely going in it look at Sam
Franklin's game he's about it looked
like he had a mating idea and instead it
switched it up look rook h5 check is
answered by Queen h4 well it's not every
day you put your queen in the way but
he's got a stoppable pass pawn the right
way to place and win for his last trick
in that position and it just didn't work
Oh block that was nice nice nice play
let's move on to the David Navarro
Wesley so game and it's over just as we
were moving over there I think by the
way it looks like topalov did make a
draw in that game and David Navarro wine
I think won that game that's Wesley soul
and fabi's game still underway
okay let's switch to it it looks like
Fabiano is no it's a mess still I've
never our wisely matched by the way six
five in a in Navarro saver now such a
tight match Wow okay where's that Queen
I couldn't even tell us where it was
Arnie has oh my goodness Bishop b2 check
talk about discovered check attacks I
think he hurry did it again he just put
his he just put his Queen in the
previous game into a discovered check
pattern and he just dropped the rook to
it discovered check there it is oh my
gosh
he's shaking his head so very sadly it's
Hari Krishna as he's done it again he
turned I think a win I think he had a
win
into a loss and Nakamura also on his
game indeed I noticed he was up upon
earlier that open did not work out this
time for Duda but Wow it looks like
Novartis a surprise over over days he's
up six five against Wesley says no
question I can't see that coming
we've also been impressed by Sam Shankly
and quasi come back this last game yes
absolutely this game was fascinating he
played this move after King h3 Knight to
c8 Knight to c8 and Queen a8 this move
is still winning key gate 7 apparently
the best way to reply to that can you
imagine playing the move King h7 Queen
seed and Bishop to b4 the threat is rook
h1 and your king is caught in what is
likely a draw but first of all it's
called a mating net but black is able
white is able to draw this position if
with correct play and the move being
Knight to e5 maybe even still winning
but Queen a8 rook to b5 and suddenly a
vicious mating threat on the board with
rook h5 check be careful because King 8
7 sorry rook rook b5 Queen C a check
King 8 7 and now the only way to win the
game the only way is to nap relay Queen
d8 you have to help out with your queen
against what's going to happen with your
king rook h5 check and now Queen h4
because after work h5 check if you have
played King g4 whoops
hello and now rook h2 and Wien age 4 and
g6 and oh nice but the guy had it all
calculated he said my Queens gonna come
back and help the Lord Queen h4 and you
have that one this pawn is unstoppable
by this bishop or this rook thanks to
the escorts of the Knights and just look
at Sam
absolutely morose devastated shocked he
can't believe he's being pummeled the
way he is
he had such a nice moment when he was up
four and a half two and a half must have
felt the momentum going his way
mm-hmm but then important back is now
the match is all tied I say tied in the
Blitz in the Ivan Ivan app but twenty
three and a half points for Richard
Richard needs one more Jennifer to
clinch victory that's right if he wins
this final game of books today right
you're his match so that might be the
one to watch yes
and that's when Topalov at 6 to 5 in
that blitz matchup but David navara up
against Wesley so I didn't see that
coming I thought Wesley on paper is the
clear favorite in the Blitz that's right
I mean 21 points and part of the reason
I made that pick and I was so wrong
about it I'm pun not intended navara
didn't seem like he was that good of a
fast player right like he actually lost
some time and you almost also time many
players but I I stand corrected as he's
showing some some good stuff today
that's the thing about the two second
increment I mean it's not only about
flagging your opponent right you also
just need to play really good really
really good moves and again shout out to
Christian for his pick today he did
choose Fabiano who scored nine and a
half out of four months with a guy or
even more for the guy on the world
championship you can see how good he is
boy you're always gonna be was not your
friend and the number two player in the
world on the planet anytime you asked me
about picks just give me the number one
rated player in the field I don't you
know if that's what this is that's my
job your job
success the best guy no look here who do
we have I think I'll pick him hey just a
second hold on time up there was a
tournament
I didn't pick Magnus you pick mama dr
that's right it was it was my turn and I
was like I guess I'll have to go with
what the leftover is Magnus all right
there was a three-way it's high so more
recent Magnus tied for and the games are
the right I mean come on this is a game
that could decide the outcome of the
match
Richard leading of course needs a one
win to clinch can he do it today or will
he do it tomorrow okay we're gonna win
right now or not let's get our pick
since I'm gonna go now I'm going with
though just say this one and I'm worried
you might think I'm just gonna call from
those guys you guys do it what's
happening okay I didn't quite fathom
rookie won by Sam he did play one
I guess he's eyeballing v4 but why would
you do that and instead he has taken and
kind of split the Queen side of black
which is very very reasonable I thought
he was going to start with a move like
Queen c2 Queen e2 h2 h3 usually a useful
kind of seven Bishop d2 plate got it
thank fish' p6 yeah and again this move
would be one looks like a waste but
that's okay III work at the 8 mm hmm
so Richards structure has been
compromised
but by every standard he's got the
better more active whoa crazy opening
alert take a look at Nakamura versus
Duda sorry guys but 9 FF 9 FF 5 D 3 9 f
6 d 4 give me that give me that
Knight takes e4 free pawn Bishop d3 and
Knight f6 allowing Knight to g5 this is
like the losses in ski gambit or some
crazy thing and g6 is virtually for she
played d6 allowing Bishop 8 7 and if you
take on a 7 with your night your King
enjoys a nice little walk Bishop 8 7
what the heck he's getting pummeled
already took did take her the night
Queen check this is move 8 of a 2700
Grand Master game King now on d7 and
knight of seven is just hand me the
material best move what a way to lose
your last and 97 is on the board right
now and he's just busted his Duda is due
to right oh oh wow the oh yeah I was
about to say the Brooklyn school of
chess and old Jack you got a walk things
out of play you say here's me a rook in
the corner your Knights gonna be hanging
why the way if black was to play King c6
I mean virtually all of his pieces are
on the first rank and his King is
charging into battle you know he's the
most develop piece on the board after
king c6
look at where all the blacks pieces lie
and the King that's that's funny
I mean chess curiosities we're on move
10
having some fun nice King is sitting on
CC you don't want to walk home this is
the last game of the day you just king
is waiting like four moves already like
what yes so white is an exchange up for
a pawn is it upon what's going on here
Jennifer what's them it's even no it's
just an exchange just an exchange but
the knight on h8 still got to get back
into the game Bishop g5 good turn good
move
Wow increase this happened to him or is
burning some clock with his big
advantage right well again kind of talk
about being wobbly and spin cycle tilt
and I think well just happened to do -
he's just played the move 95 Queen e2
crazy stuff gym Sam Shanklin by the way
he has a bit of an edge
better finish not as not as interesting
as the game of Nakamura but I do like
you have draw odds yeah you said that
Richard was gonna win the game was
definitely terrible I know it really is
bad I mean that looks like a step in the
wrong direction to my eyes because after
Knight d3 this blockading night is like
immovable after g3 and this night on g6
is going to be tethered to the e5 on so
it's a denied at 4 right away
g4 another reason that you might
play g3s you could meet this move g4
with the move f4 Richard well he's
making it hard making a treatment f5
okay that just that was really blowing
the position right noxee seven check
though Jen look look at this I mean okay
Sam Sam's beginning oh okay Richard is
just amazing Sam said okay let me just
play Knight c5 so I can threaten 96
check and give me the pawn on d4 what do
you got for and I don't think he's got a
lot for in terms of give me the pot
exchange I'll give that process and I'll
have a d6 so King takes d4 92 check King
e5 Knight take C 1 upon 3 you just I
wanted to escorts but okay King takes
III grabbing pawns always a good idea
very good idea let me play d6 and be
much better G you were really close on
this one Maurice he just could not catch
fabbi though who's having well what can
I say
just
[Music]
terms of wait a minute why did Sam go d7
he could have played h3 check a move ago
okay this may be still a winning
reckoning rookie five let's go Sam five
I guess it's winning rook g2 yeah well
he's still winning it rook g2 up chief
you're up g5 followed by rook chief King
f3 what's this he's gonna take that pawn
I think I thought he was gonna go King
f3 actually okay well Sam has his ideas
let's hope for his sake he's right ooh
nice Tricky's what's the trick if you go
rook a to a6 perhaps yeah and then came
g6 and then you have to go protect your
idea same idea I think Richard was so
lucky it's Richard in front not what you
want in game should now you can say you
got a g7 but this is not now okay g5 and
it's looking over oh he's getting a
meeting what is the point this King has
got to go in front of that a pawn it's
not the VIN but this is not a drinker
this looks like Vancouver getting the
rook to the F file it should draw but
remember this is not classical chest
just blitz chess hard to remember time
as a fact you're trying to build up the
clock and he's just got his rook out oh
it's over yeah you can resign now he
forgot to give God a check and now push
the pawn and won the game
humming back in the last round there you
go baby yeah Navarre has a one-point
lead you can
Wesley even the score in the Blitz
exactly he's got a massive lead in the
rabbit and Wesley no it's a bishops up
opposite color ending and Wesley's in
trouble eyes yeah
Wesley is fighting his way back push it
yeah push him baby well done very
successful day for David Navarre
absolutely he's still not looking green
in the match but he ended up scoring +1
today hey Wesley so and Wow if you look
at the bar there is a good student I
would tell my students of your pieces
yeah yeah I might be a 2,700 Grand
Master but I do set up my pieces this is
I probably learned this in the Maurice
Ashley school Nakamura by the way did
win once again against dude at the
silver medalist from the world blitz
championship getting a lesson I want to
say from the car was just I think you
know one of the greatest blitz players
I've ever seen in my life ever yeah yeah
Magnus is also just a monster monster
Blitzen rapid player what can you
Magnus cars boom that hasn't been said
but for me Nakamura is it's some talent
and we have thank you very much guys I'm
here with Lanier Dominguez after a
fairly balanced day at the office
Lanier how would you assess your
performance
well it wasn't especially good I mean in
one quite right from the beginning I was
too slow again but then I was I think I
was able to improve to play a bit faster
and and better but still it wasn't
enough to to improve so much more high
score but okay we have one final day
let's see what happens what is the
strategy tomorrow you need to score big
what are you going to do differently
well just try to play fast and just do
my best and not put so much pressure
like I mean thinking about the score or
something or just trying to play and see
what happens and uh last but not least
oh wow what do you think about the
format of this match well it's very
interesting I mean this 15 minutes I for
some reason I thought it's more like
Robbie that it felt more like plates I
don't know if it's me that I was too
slow but it felt almost like plates 25
minutes at least you have some time to
think but I think in general it's it's
quite spectacular this fast time
controls and I always enjoyed absolutely
we remember last year's match against
Wesley so and there was actually blood
on the chest clock so good luck in the
rest of the match and we'll see you
tomorrow let's go to Maurice with Sam
Shanklin well he didn't have a first
great first few days in the rapid but
showing his skills now in the Blitz
portion the US Champion from 2018 Sam
Shanklin Sam a champion like you you
want to win the matches when you realize
you couldn't win the match anymore
rapid how did you approach the Blitz
today and made this comeback excuse me
I'm going to win all 12 games tomorrow
and win without a playoff what are you
talking no I mean yeah of course you
just have to keep on fighting no matter
what I mean obviously I'm gonna keep on
fighting tomorrow because I'm gonna try
to win all 12 games I give myself I
don't know one in a million chance this
seems about right but of course you have
to try um no you just have to keep your
head on straight and I was sort of
looking forward to the Blitz Oh actually
I'd my blitz has been pretty lousy for a
long time and I really put a lot of work
into it recently and I'm realizing how I
need to put working to wrap it instead I
mean I thought my blitz I played pretty
well today it's always hot you've been
working with in blitz just playing a lot
in trying to get better it's because all
this stuff I've been working on for the
past years was basically geared towards
classical tresca's for a long time
that's really all that mattered even for
elite players but now that there's
Grantchester and all these other top
level blitz and rapid events I had to
start working on those but well I I just
been playing a lot in trying to make
more intuitive decisions and not worry
as much about calculation cuz obviously
you don't have time in a blitz game and
a rapid game you sort of do but this is
faster than rapid evening because it's
15 minutes it's out of 25 but I've been
working on it
I think clearly especially in rapid
there's a long way to go because we have
the same rating and he just led me up I
mean it was really uncompetitive at some
points but you know I think at least for
blood so I'm doing all right people felt
like he was him being the European rapid
champion that you picked a really tough
opponent but you could have picked
anybody why this particular opponent was
clearly very I thought it would be fun
and what I'll say after I was criticized
for picking Maxime last time who also
crushed me as I would rather be a fool
than a coward and I wanted to choose
someone who I thought would challenge me
and who I thought would be really fun
and honestly like I don't want to berate
anyone who plays the Berlin all day long
every day I mean that's your
professional players what you have to do
sometimes but something like rapport is
just incredibly imaginative I mean I
think we've had a single boring game
this entire match I don't know maybe I
should have chosen someone quote-unquote
easier I mean I looked at our ratings
and so were the same I just didn't
really think he was gonna be that much
better wrap up and clearly he was or at
least he showed it this part but you
know I'm I'm glad that I picked the guy
did even though it did the rapid face
didn't go very well
I don't think anybody's gonna call you a
coward you like tremendous heart it
might help me a fool yeah maybe right
screw sure anyway thanks very much for
your fight and good luck tomorrow
Thanks well done Sam and great comeback
we have a Christian upstairs with David
Navarro Thank You Maurice I'm here with
number one cheque player David navara
after a very good day at the office
David how do you assess your performance
in the first day of blitz okay I was
playing much better than in on the
previous day's today even though I still
ate quite many mistakes but it's
inevitable in blitz I mean the games
were very interesting and of course I
missed some chances was they also did so
it was interesting you still need to
catch up on on the score what are you
going to do differently tomorrow
no I'm seven points behind so it's
unrealistic to catch up but I want to
play as well as I can I will try today I
was much closer to it I mean I can play
better sometimes but I'm no longer that
quick and when I'm short of time I'm
making big mistakes of course you've
played a lot of matches here in Europe
as well how do you like this format okay
it's very interesting especially for
spectators and there are many strong
players and I like it very much
I'm glad that I was invited even though
okay I think there are also many other
players who did is I have to play rather
than me but okay I'm happy to be here
and finally what is your max score in
puzzle rush you are doing it in the
basement yesterday I don't know I
watched so much I don't know so well so
I don't know how is it being rated I
better is out on the of the day
yesterday I think but I mean I don't
know but some times were someone gave me
one advice even though I haven't hadn't
asked for it I mean I can't see such
tactics quickly but I think there's it's
irrelevant because it's way too simple
I'm
many of those puzzles and okay I don't
care well you definitely beat my
all-time high so congratulations on that
thank you very much and we're looking
forward to see you tomorrow
let's go back to Maurice well we are
with someone who definitely thinks those
puzzles are way too easy Fabriano
Caruana who has done a lot of remarkable
things in his career and certainly today
as he has clinched his match against
bent Allah Hari Krishna first of all
congratulations uh you must have felt
that you were going to clinch the match
with such a big score and rapid how do
you keep yourself motivated as you kept
on winning games even afterwards well
it's not I mean I I thought I would win
the match coming into today but it's not
a guarantee and and you you really I
mean it's the worst feeling to actually
ruin a match where it's pretty much all
in your hands and you have you huge lead
so yeah I still had a lot of motivation
and even after the match was
theoretically over I still felt pretty
motivated to play but okay overall the
quality today wasn't too great a lot of
games were decided by really crude
blunders near the end I think the main
difference today was that I was seen
these kind of small tactics when we had
a few seconds left a bit faster than he
was and that's a sign I mean he
plundered Queen with page 6 and then
Bishop when he played Russia five in one
of the games Bishop b2 but yeah he's
pulled a lot of winning positions which
he had and if he has converted then
there would have been a very close tag
how do you explain such a strong player
making mistakes like that I mean we're
used to seeing much lower rate of
players plunder but I'm sure they're
happy to see that the top player could
make such a simple blunder as well but
also somewhat surprised that a 27 plus
player has been in the top ten could
make these kind of errors oh when you
have five seconds left your brain is not
really functioning properly I mean you
you can't really think about a position
with us you know with only one second
for a move so you have to lie entirely
basically on some sort of pattern
recognition and and trying to spot small
tactics that's about it I mean to you so
it's really not that surprising and you
see a lot of top games will will end in
crew blunders and that's one of the
strengths of like let's say he call her
that he sees these tactics probably
better than anyone else have to in the
final stages we're only a few seconds
left and he I think this is just a huge
advantage in blitz to to be able to spot
tactics and not blunder and you're that
what everyone does it I mean Magnus will
wonder any all the bus players in the
world will blunder when it comes down to
the last few seconds I know you say
doesn't matter at all to you what you're
getting forty nine rating points in
blitz just today and then to reason you
into the top ten in the world in the
live rankings and blitz
how do you assess that as an improvement
better men or irrelevant yeah again I I
don't I it doesn't matter too much to me
I'm still mainly looking at classical
radiance those are the ones which I
think everyone puts most talking to of
course like I said before blitz and
rapid I mean the best players in class
in the world in classical are still the
highest rated blitz and wrap it as well
but but it's not as important to me the
rating you're saying yeah the radio but
now with the Grantchester expanding five
different events in the rapid and blitz
London chess classic will have rapid in
blitz as well you played in that as well
as in rapid in blitz now really
featuring prominently I care about my
results in rapid blitz I just I mean I
don't look at the rating too much and
generally speaking if you play well the
rating follows but yeah of course Robin
blitz is very very important these days
it's I ones I play more rapid on boots
in classical but it's it's a very
prominent part of every top player
schedule let me just make a clear point
you do care about your rating and
classical don't you or no of course yeah
I mean I mean I also so used to looking
at that because it was basically a
ticket to the candidates and I I mean
last time like I qualified to candidates
was by
rating so I'm very used to looking at my
classical ratings um maybe this year I
don't have to pay as much attention to
it but when it was a race between
Kramnik Wesley and me I mean I was
basically looking at it every day
all our radians I had to to make sure
that that I would get a spot final
question
tomorrow's games you have 12 games that
for you really don't matter because
you've already sown of the match and
they're not rated how do you want to
close this out are you highly motivated
to win all the games yeah okay I can
relax a bit because it's there's not
really much at stake except to play good
chess which is always the best thing I
think and hopefully both of us can play
better now that there's really no
pressure on either one our
congratulations to you avianna
on the first to win a showdown match
winner as he clinched the $36,000
jennifer and the only winner of today as
we turned out we got it done
Fabiano carolina though seriously big
congrats
$36,000 in the bag and of course we're
always proud of st. Louis his own Bobby
Cara wanna yeah well I thought that we
had some really really dazzling matchups
great play by Hikaru Nakamura against
the silver medalist but let's go over to
Maryse and share your thoughts on this
the first day of blitz well it was
clearly very exciting lots of good blitz
matches we want to see that and I think
more and more we're noticing yes maybe
you want to separate the blitz and rapid
scores because that way the blitz
portion will matter and if it if it
didn't matter then three of the matches
we see we see today would be simply
thrilling to be looking for the numbers
as that's going to matter as far as
prize money would be concerned and all
and bragging rights as well and we'll
keep an eye on it tomorrow because I'm
sure okay Sam is saying he's gonna try
to win all 12 games that I'll bet won't
happen
knowing me I might lose that bet but
that still is highly unlikely of the
unlikeliest but still these players are
competitive they want to play well they
want to show their stuff on the highest
stage right here in st. Louis and so it
should be fun and we'll be here of
course last day guys we've been here a
while
all the actions you want the person to
be actually able to pay but seriously
what a day had so much fun calling the
splits and just what constantly
astonishes me is how high the quality
can be when you bring some of the top
players in the world that vert blitz
games I mean some of them are really
just incredible to watch and thanks
everybody for viewing tomorrow we're
gonna be back same time same place same
format twelve exciting blitz games 1250
Central time that's 150 in the East
Coast this is gen jihadi signing off for
grandmasters yessir Sara want Maurice
Ashley and Christian Correa upstairs
thank you for joining us see you all
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]